Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zu Ausgabe 77 hier in unserer Gesprächsreihe.
Und heute hat mich der Weg nach Österreich geführt, konkret sitze ich hier in Wien und heute wollen wir sprechen über Organisationen.
Konkreter über die Forschung über Organisationen und dazu begrüße ich erst mal meinen Gesprächspartner,
nämlich den Leonhard Dobusch, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Leonhard wir kennen uns schon eine Weile, weil wir im selben Umfeld uns bewegen,
wenngleich auch auf vollkommen unterschiedliche Art und Weise.
Dazu kommen wir auch noch, aber vielleicht machen wir fest, was du eigentlich so machst und vor allem auch bisher so gemacht hast.
Konkret bist du ja derzeit Professor an der Universität Innsbruck, auch wenn wir jetzt gerade in Wien sitzen
am Institut für Organisation und Lernen und da als Professor für Organisationsforschung, kann man das so umschreiben?
Genau, für Betriebswirtschaftslehre mit Schwerpunkt Organisation.
Aber das war nicht immer das Thema.
Ich würde schon sagen, dass Organisation eigentlich mich als Thema begleitet hat.
Eigentlich sogar die allererste Prüfung in meinem Betriebswirtschaftsstudium in Linz war auch die Prüfung in Organisation
und ich habe gleich ganz schlecht abgeschnitten.
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich gewesen.
Also in der Prüfung selber wusste ich es noch gar nicht, ich ging da rein und dachte mir,
ja geht so weiter wie in der Schule, alles easy.
Und dann war es aber so, am nächsten Tag, also das war am Freitagabend, am Samstagvormittag hatte der Dozent die Klausuren korrigiert
und ich hatte irgendwie so eine 4- und war doch erst was erstaunt und habe ihn dann gefragt, was war da falsch?
Er sagte, falsch war nichts, aber die Fragen waren nur der Vorwand, alles hin zu schreiben, was man weiß
und das hatte ich irgendwie nicht so auf dem Schirm.
Und hatte dann gleich mal Panik, ob das mit dem Studium doch nicht so easy wird.
Aber warum hast du denn damit überhaupt angefangen?
Ja, also eigentlich ich habe mich immer sehr viel schon interessiert und ich habe in Linz, wo ich auch geboren und aufgewachsen bin,
dann habe ich zwei Studien gemacht.
Ich habe während dem Zivildienst schon mit BWL begonnen, da konnte man eben nebenbei so ein paar Kurse machen.
Und das habe ich eigentlich genommen, weil ich mich nicht so richtig entscheiden konnte.
BWL hat auf mich so gewirkt wie so ein, in Deutschland würde man sagen, ein Kessel buntes.
Also da war irgendwie ja die BWL-Fächer, aber dann war auch VWL dabei, Soziologie, Recht,
also es war eigentlich von allem was.
Und das fand ich insofern ganz gut und dann habe ich noch Jura, also österreichisches Recht,
in Österreich sagt man ja „Jus“ studiert.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, wirklich nur gemacht, weil mein Vater, der auch Jurist war, gefunden hat, das ist Herrschaftswissen.
Ist nicht ganz falsch, glaube ich.
Genau, die zwei Studien haben sich gut ergänzt, das eine hatte große Prüfungen und das andere kleine während des Semesters.
Und am Ende war auch nicht ganz klar, in welche Richtung ich gehe.
BWL und Jura da könnte man ja meinen, ja das wäre gut für Wirtschaftsanwaltskanzleien,
also habe ich mal mir einen Sommer lang das angesehen und entschieden, sicher nicht.
Und habe dann aber noch das Gerichtsjahr gemacht, so heißt das in Österreich, in Deutschland wäre das so was wie Referendariat, glaube ich.
Da war ich also an verschiedenen Gerichten, Bezirksgericht, Landesgericht und so.
Und dann war aber, und das war schon, glaube ich, die entscheidende Stelle dann,
während dessen habe ich mich beworben für Doktoratsstellen und in Deutschland hat mich dann eben die deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft
bzw. ein graduierten Kollege an der freien Universität Berlin in ihr Förderprogramm aufgenommen
und ich habe dann dort, ich kam dann 2005, ist auch schon wieder lange her, nach Berlin im Oktober,
das werde ich nie vergessen, ich kam dahin, hatte ein Stipendium, 1000 Euro im Monat,
quasi ohne Sozialversicherung, Steuern, brutto für netto.
So ein Grundeinkommen.
Und meine Aufgabe war, meine Dis zu schreiben in den nächsten zweieinhalb Jahren und das fand ich schon mal unfassbar toll.
Genau.
Ich habe in diesen zwei-drei Jahren so viel gelesen wie nie wieder zuvor und nie wieder danach.
Und habe mich da schon sehr privilegiert gefühlt, obwohl ich jetzt nicht Geld verdient habe,
aber einfach so die Aufgabe, mit einem Thema sich zu beschäftigen, sich zu vertiefen, zu lesen, drüber zu schreiben,
ein paar Kurse besuchen, aber die wollte ich auch besuchen, zu Methodik und so.
Das war schon sehr super.
Und mein Thema der Dis war Open Source Software in großen Stadtverwaltungen, konkret am Desktop.
Der Titel war dann später mal „Windows versus Linux, Markt, Organisation, Pfad“.
Aber da ging es schon genau darum, es gibt eigentlich so eine Alternative, die keine Lizenzkosten hat,
die natürlich nicht kostenlos ist, aber wo ich zumindest das Geld nicht nach Redmond überweise in die USA.
Und warum ist es so schwierig, am Desktop von Windows auf Linux zu wechseln?
Ich meine, heute mit der Cloud stellt sich diese Frage ja schon wieder ein bisschen anders,
aber damals war das schon eine Frage und das war rund um diese Zeit, wo München als erste große Stadt im deutschsprachigen Raum gesagt hat,
wir probieren, wir wagen es.
Und in diesem graduierten Kolleg, wo das Thema eigentlich Pfadabhängigkeit war, war genau das das Thema,
wie kann man so einen Pfad, so einen etablierten technologischen Pfad, wie zum Beispiel Windows am Desktop,
wie kann man das vielleicht doch verlassen, brechen?
Im Nachhinein muss man sehen, der Pfad war so stark, dass selbst München nicht wirklich geschafft hat.
Die sind dann zwar mal weg für zehn Jahre und dann haben sie wieder umgestellt, zurück auf Windows.
Was heißt der Begriff Pfadabhängigkeit?
Pfadabhängigkeit beschreibt die Situation, dass historisch man verschiedene Optionen hatte
und dann aufgrund von eigentlich oftmals auch emergenten, das heißt nicht vorhersehbaren kleineren Effekten,
Events sich ein Pfad herausbildet, es quasi auf eine dieser vielen Varianten hinausläuft,
durch sogenannte selbstverstärkende Mechanismen.
Ich bringe gleich noch ein Beispiel.
So dass am Ende, wenn dieser Pfad mal etabliert ist, es ganz schwer wird, von diesem Pfad wieder abzuweichen.
Teilweise weil diese Alternativen, die es am Anfang gab, dann gar nicht mehr existieren.
Und weil dann eben so etwas wie, im Internet spricht man dann von, Netzwerkeffekt eintritt,
weil eben alle anderen auch auf diese Option gesetzt haben, müsste man die alle gleichzeitig dazu bringen,
wieder zu wechseln und das ist sehr schwer.
Also man könnte jetzt sagen, Facebook als Platzhirsch für soziale Netzwerke, es gab mal Friendster,
es gab mal MySpace, es gab mal in Deutschland StudiVZ und MeinVZ und so weiter, es gab werkenntwen,
und alle die sind irgendwie ausgestorben und dieser eine Pfad, der Facebook-Pfad, der hat sich durchgesetzt.
Und es gibt immer wieder Versuche, den zu brechen, zum Beispiel auch aus der Open Source Szene heraus,
zum Beispiel Diaspora, aber die tun sich eben so schwer, nicht weil Facebook so tolle Funktionalität hätte guten Datenschutz,
sondern weil alle deine Freunde dort sind und dann …
Die sind halt da.
Die sind halt da und wenn du alleine woanders hingehst, bist du dort auch alleine und ein soziales Netzwerk,
wenn du alleine bist, das ist nicht sehr hilfreich.
/lacht/ Das stimmt und bei Betriebssystemen ist es ja dann nicht sehr viel anders gewesen mit der Dominanz von Windows.
Die sind halt jetzt einfach in dem Markt da, also zumindest im Business-Bereich und kaum rauszubekommen.
Und da war in meiner Doktorarbeit auch ein zählender Punkt und da kommen wir zur Organisation.
Dass die Organisation einen großen Unterschied macht.
Also wenn ich alleine Windows einsetze, dann kann ich sogar relativ einfach wechseln.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob du Windows jetzt verwendest oder Linux auf deinem Laptop,
aber als Einzelperson ist meine Abhängigkeit beschränkt.
Es ist manchmal nicht toll, wenn ich mit Leuten kommuniziere und deren Files bekomme, die dann vielleicht nicht so gut funktionieren unter Linux,
aber das geht noch und da gibt es für alles einen Workaround.
Und wenn ich für mich das entschieden habe, dass ich einmal mir das gut einrichte mit einer Alternative,
ich selber fahre auch Mac und keinen Windowsrechner privat und in Harvard,
aber in den Städten war das Problem, das Windows quasi war der Standard, teilweise nicht mal explizit eingeführt,
das ist so entstanden, also man hat da irgendwann mal elektronische Schreibmaschinen durch PCs ersetzt
und da war halt Windows drauf und dann war Windows da und dann hat man die vernetzt.
Und auf einmal hatte man ein Windows-Netzwerk.
Und das nächste, was passiert ist, man hat begonnen, Fachanwendungen zu programmieren, zu bestellen, zu kaufen.
Irgendwelche Detailtools, die man nur in der Verwaltung einsetzt und die hat man halt speziell für Windows entwickelt.
Da gab es gar keine Variante oder eine Alternative für irgendein anderes Betriebssystem.
Und das haben alle diese Abteilungen in der Stadtverwaltung für sich so dezentral entschieden.
Und was das Ganze noch zusammengehalten hat, war die gemeinsame Windows-Basis.
Und wenn man dann sagt, so jetzt wollen wir wechseln, dann ist eben nicht nur so, dass ich jeden einzelnen Computer umstellen muss
von Windows auf Linux, sondern ich muss jede einzelne Fachanwendung entweder neu programmieren, neu anschaffen
und da reden wir von 700-800 Fachanwendungen, die in so einer Stadtverwaltung wie München oder Berlin oder Wien,
das waren so die Fälle, die ich mir angesehen habe, wo es Diskussionen gab, umzustellen.
Das ist dann auf einmal ein riesiger Aufwand.
Also man kennt das ja auch, es gibt teilweise immer noch Anwendungen, die irgendwie so auf einem Terminal laufen,
weil man sie irgendwann mal in den 80ern drauf programmiert hat und es dann einfach Aufwand ist, die umzustellen.
Und solange sie läuft, warum soll ich da quasi Geld in die Hand nehmen?
Und das heißt, da merkt man schon, in einer Organisation, wo es eben drum geht, arbeitsteilig vorzugehen
und diese Arbeitsteilung dann aber auch wieder zu koordinieren, weil das ist so das Grundproblem des Organisierens ist ja,
einerseits wie verteile ich die Arbeit, die zu tun ist in einer Organisation, auf die Köpfe der Organisation?
Wer soll was machen?
Und wie führe ich das dann wieder zusammen.
Also wir haben immer beides, Arbeitsteilung und Koordination.
Und da kommt es ständig zu solchen Pfadabhängigkeiten.
Man hat mal gesagt, okay, das teilen wir so auf und dann spezialisieren sich diese einzelnen Abteilungen
und werden besser in dem was sie tun.
Was manchmal aber dazu führt, dass die Koordination schwieriger wird, weil die entwickeln eine eigene Sprache
und dann wird das wieder einen Herausforderung und dann muss man sich oftmals sehr bemühen,
dass diese Abteilungsidentitäten auch zum Beispiel nicht überhand nehmen.
Das waren also die Pfadabhängigkeiten.
Also dieser Graduierten Kolleg in Berlin hieß glaube ich „Pfade organisatorischer Prozesse“, das beschreibt es ja eigentlich schon ganz gut.
Um vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz die persönliche Geschichte abzurunden, dabei ist es ja jetzt nicht geblieben.
Ich habe ja schon gesagt, es kam dann auf jeden Fall noch die Professur in Innsbruck dazu, aber vorher, glaube ich, auch nochmal in Berlin.
Ich war zehn Jahre in Berlin, also bis 2016, und quasi unmittelbar nach der Promotion bin ich ein Jahr nach Köln gegangen
und habe die Wohnung in Berlin aber nicht mal aufgegeben.
War da am Max-Planck-Institut für Gesellschaftsforschung für ein Jahr.
Und in der Zeit auch mal kurz für zwei-drei Monate in Stanford, da allerdings an der Law School
und habe da schon versucht auch, irgendwie diesen juristischen Faden ein bisschen aufzunehmen.
Weil von dieser Open Source Software, da spielen ja Open Source Software Lizenzen eine große Rolle,
und zu der Zeit hat man dann auch versucht, diese Idee von Open Source in anderen Bereichen einzuführen
und hat gesagt, naja vielleicht kann man noch andere digitale Güter offen lizenzieren und vielleicht führt auch das dazu,
dass das irgendwie dann kreativer, vielfältiger, freier zugänglich wird.
Und das war so mein zweites großes Thema, creative commons Lizenzen, also offene Lizenzen jenseits von Software,
für Bilder, für Texte, für Musik, für Videos.
Und außerdem habe ich da eben die Chance gesehen, sozusagen meine Organisationsforschungskompetenz mit meinem juristischen Hintergrund ein bisschen zu verbinden
und habe da am Anfang nicht gewusst, auf was ich mich da einlasse, wenn ich mich mit dem Urheberrecht im digitalen Zeitalter auseinandersetze,
das war nicht nur schön.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und ist bis heute Quelle nie enden wollender Frustration.
Ja.
Aber gut, und dann bin ich aber zurück eben nach Berlin, war dann an der FU Berlin zuerst als Post Doc
und dann auch dreieinhalb Jahre Juniorprofessor für Organisationstheorie, bevor ich eben den Ruf an die Uni Innsbruck bekommen habe.
Das war jetzt nicht so, weil ich unbedingt zurück nach Österreich wollte.
Also ich wurde immer von deutschen Kollegen dann, ah du gehst zurück nach Österreich?
Und ich sage, naja ich komme aus Oberösterreich, Linz, für mich ist Tirol ungefähr so fremd wie Berlin war.
Also die sprechen, glaube ich, noch mehr anders als die Berliner.
Und es war jetzt nicht so, ich will zurück nach Österreich, sondern wie das halt so ist in der Wissenschaft,
wenn man in der Wissenschaft bleiben will, dann geht man dorthin, wo man den Ruf bekommt und ist sehr froh,
wenn man einen Ruf bekommt.
Und ich würde sagen, ich habe auch wirklich ein ziemliches Glück, die Uni Innsbruck ist in Österreich sicher einer der besten Unis.
Ich würde sagen, in meinem Feld so die zweitbeste nach der Wirtschaftsuniversität Wien.
Und was heißt gut, es ist ein forschungsorientiertes Umfeld.
Gut aufgestellt.
Ja, vor allem mir zum Beispiel ist sehr wichtig, theorienpluralistisch, methodenpluralistisch.
Also es sind dann nicht nur Leute, die Regressionen rechnen, es gibt da auch, was ich hier mache, so qualitativ fallstudienbasierte Ansätze.
Und es ist einfach auch nicht nur eine theoretische Richtung, die dort irgendwie dominiert.
Und das ist zum Beispiel was unter dem volkswirtschaftliche Fakultäten viel leiden, dazu habe ich auch ein bisschen geforscht.
Aber auch in der BWL ist das keineswegs so, dass das so ist, dass an all diesen Fakultäten man so offen ist auch für vielleicht ein bisschen Projekte,
die jetzt nicht nur Unternehmensforschung sind, im Sinne von wie kann man einen höheren Marktanteil erzielen, so.
Die Fälle, die Unternehmen oder auch die Phänomene, die mich interessieren,
die waren schon irgendwie nie nur auf diesem betriebswirtschaftlich engen Bereich der Unternehmen beschränkt.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen was zu Offenheit in Unternehmenskontexten auch geforscht,
aber ansonsten mich immer viel auch für NGOs, also irgendwelche gemeinnützigen Organisationen interessiert,
für digitale Gemeinschaften, für Plattformen, bis hin zu, da treffen sich unsere, glaube ich, Welten wieder ein bisschen,
mein wichtigster Aufsatz, den ich auch in meinem Berufungsvortrag an der Uni Innsbruck vorgetragen habe,
beschäftigt sich ironischerweise mit Hackernetzwerken oder sogenannten Hackernetzwerken.
Nämlich das war ein Aufsatz, der hieß „Fluidity, Identity, Organizationality“, also „Fluidität, Identität und Organitionalität“
und es geht um den Fall von Anonymous, dem sogenannten Hackernetzwerk.
Ja.
Und da muss man schon sagen, das ist durchaus erschienen in einer Managementzeitschrift, im Journal of Management Studies.
Aber natürlich bekommt man dann auch die Frage, okay und was hat das mit Management und Betriebswirtschaft zu tun?
Und wenn ich das jetzt kurz beantworten darf, würde ich sagen, einerseits finde ich, da kann man durchaus was davon lernen.
Die Frage, die wir uns da angesehen haben, war, Anonymous, jeder kann für Anonymous sprechen.
Also ich kann jetzt ins Internet gehen und sagen, ich bin Anonymous und eine Aktion verkünden.
Wir sind viele.
Wir sind viele, genau, habt Angst vor uns, wir sind Legion.
Aber die Frage ist, was ist, wenn es umstritten ist, ob es wirklich Anonymous war?
Und da haben wir uns so quasi mal alle Aktionen, wo die Diskussion war, war das Anonymous oder nicht, angeschaut,
die wir so finden konnten, das waren so 150 so in den letzten Jahren.
Und dann haben wir geschaut, okay wo war es umstritten, wo war nicht klar, war es Anonymous oder nicht?
Und das waren so acht-neun Fälle, gar nicht so viele, die haben wir dann genauer angesehen.
Und da wiederum zwei ausgewählt, die wir dann ganz detailliert auf wirklich einzelner Sprechaktebene angeschaut haben.
Wie wurde diese Frage gelöst?
Also wenn man nicht weiß, wer Anonymous ist …
Also ein Fall war da zum Beispiel, jemand hat verkündet Operation Facebook, wir greifen jetzt Facebook an
und hat das angekündigt für den 05. November, das ist ein sehr wichtiges Datum in dieser Szene.
Remember, remember, the fifth of November.
Genau, das ist quasi der Guy Fawkes Day, wer das auf Wikipedia nachlesen will.
Und dann kam gleich mal von einem sehr prominenten Account, der Anonymous zugeschrieben wird,
also da merkt man schon, Anonymous Accounts, die von mehreren hunderttausend Leuten irgendwie gefolgt werden,
die haben halt mehr Autorität und die speist sich meist daraus, dass sie in der Vergangenheit erfolgreiche Anonymous Aktionen angekündigt hatten.
Und die haben dann gleich mal gesagt, nein das ist gar nicht Anonymous, das ist Fake.
Und dann haben sie aber eine halbe Stunde, zwei, drei Stunden später wieder was getwittert und gesagt so,
okay, also vielleicht doch nicht Fake, es machen einige Anons und nicht alle Anons sind damit einverstanden,
also quasi zurückgerudert.
Und dann ging das so ein halbes Jahr, haben die quasi immer wieder so gedroht, ha Facebook macht euch bereit
und andere in Anonymous dachten offenbar, oh mein Gott das ist schlecht für unseren Ruf, wir haben keine Chance gegen Facebook,
diese Server mit unseren Pseudohackingtools, die wir haben, da haben wir keine Chance gegen Facebook.
Und wirklich am 04. November, also am Tag davor, bevor es losgehen hätte sollen,
hat dann irgendjemand die persönlichen Daten von diesem Inhaber dieses Operation Facebook Accounts quasi ins Netz gestellt.
Man nennt das Doxing in der Szene, also man hat seinen richtigen Namen, seine Anschrift, seine Mailadresse, seine Handynummer quasi ins Netz gestellt
und damit gesagt, also Anthony hieß der Typ und ihn damit quasi rausgeworfen, weil wenn du Anthony bist, kannst du nicht Anonymous sein.
Aber was ist sozusagen die Moral von der Geschichte aus einer Organisationsforschungsperspektive?
Das war ein unfassbar aufwendiger, ich würde jetzt sagen, performativer Sprechakt.
Also man hat hier quasi nicht, indem man ihn quasi ausrecherchiert hat und dann seine Identität veröffentlicht hat,
hat man ihn quasi rausgeworfen.
Also man muss nicht quasi aufgenommen werden bei Anonymous, jeder kann mal sagen, ich bin Anonymous,
aber offensichtlich kann man trotzdem rausgeworfen werden und hat auf diese Art und Weise wieder stabilisiert,
was es ist, das Anonymous ausmacht und was Anonymous tut.
Und da gibt es ein paar so Fälle, wo das lief.
Und ich würde sagen, wenn man den Bezug zu Unternehmen herstellt, dann ist diese Frage, welche Identität haben wir,
wer sind wir uns was wollen wir sein, die bei Anonymous natürlich hochgradig prekär ist,
die immer wieder neu ausgehandelt werden muss,
das kann auch in Organisationskontexten sein.
Also man stelle sich vor, zwei Unternehmen fusionieren.
Also da ist auch mal die Frage, da kommen zwei etablierte Organisationsidentitäten zusammen,
wie sieht dann diese neue Identität aus?
Setzt sich der eine durch oder will man da einen Hybrid schaffen?
Und für das Management stellt sich die Frage, selbst wenn ich jetzt einen Idee habe, wie diese Identität ausschauen soll,
was kann ich als Manager tun oder als Managerin, um hier zu diesem Ziel dieser Identität zu kommen?
Und da kommt es genau auch wieder darauf an, dass man eben nicht nur was sagt, sondern auch tut, also sehr performativ agiert.
Also ich sage ein Beispiel, wenn ich sage, flache Hierarchien, aber ich bestehe drauf, dass mich die Leute per Sie anreden
und ich lass die Sekretärin mir den Kaffee bringen jeden Tag in der Früh, dann ist das unglaubwürdig.
Also da muss ich dann vielleicht selber auch mal den Geschirrspüler in der Gemeinschaftsküche ausräumen,
obwohl ich quasi der Chef bin.
Um jetzt nicht gleich zu weit zu springen, würde ich ganz gerne noch kurz nochmal zwei Ausschnitte deiner Biografie nochmal hier kurz reintragen
und dann vielleicht mal was die Organisation betrifft nochmal so ein bisschen in die Geschichte zurückspulen.
Du bist ja auch noch in den ZDF Fernsehrat berufen worden, wie kam es dazu?
Ja, also das war eigentlich so kurz bevor ich nach Österreich ging, also 2016 im Juli habe ich das erst angetreten meine Position im Fernsehrat.
Und das ist schon ganz interessant, weil ich bin eigentlich nur deshalb drinnen,
weil 2014 das Deutsche Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat, der Fernsehrat und auch die Rundfunkräte ganz allgemein,
also öffentlich-rechtliche Sender haben quasi Aufsichtsgremien, die versuchen sollen,
die Rückbindung an die Gesellschaft einerseits sicherzustellen
und gleichzeitig aber für eine gewisse Staatsferne zu sorgen.
Also da dürfen nicht nur Politiker drin sein.
Staatsfern heißt nicht staatsfrei, also da sind durchaus Politiker drin, aber da waren eben sehr viele Politiker drin.
Und dann hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht in Deutschland entschieden, da sind zu viele drin, mehr als ein Drittel geht nicht.
Daraufhin hat man das Gremium verkleinert und sich überlegt, okay wie füllen wir das?
Und dann hat sich jedes Bundesland in Deutschland, jedes Land hat sich einen Bereich ausgesucht.
Also zum Beispiel Thüringen hat sich für LGBTQ entschieden, Schleswig-Holstein mit der südschlesischen Minderheit
für den Bereich Minderheitssprachen.
Und dann war der große Streit, wer darf modern innovativ sein und digital machen.
Und da haben sich die Bayern und die Berliner gestritten.
Am Ende hat man, ich würde ja fast sagen, eine österreichische Lösung gefunden, die Bayern durften nämlich dann Digitales befüllen und Berlin Internet.
Also das ist wirklich so, das steht im Rundfunk Staatsvertrag, für den Bereich Internet entsendet das Land Berlin einen Vertreter.
Und für den Bereich Digitales das Land Bayern.
Und weil das eben staatsfern sein sollte, mussten die das wieder delegieren an wen auch immer, das ist landesgesetzlich geregelt.
Die Bayern haben gesagt, naja digital, da nehmen wir den Bitkom, den Branchenverband der Telekommunikationsindustrie.
Da weiß man, der wird von der Deutschen Telekom dominiert, die haben gedacht, weiß eh jeder, na gut dann brauchen wir uns auch nicht genieren.
Also haben sie wirklich den Cheflobbyisten der Deutschen Telekom da reingesetzt, das ist mein special friend.
Und in Berlin hat man das anders gelöst, da hat man vier Vereine gesagt, die müssen sich auf eine Person einigen.
Das war dann der Chaos Computer Club, D64, das ist so ein SPD naher Netzpolitikverein, dann MediaNet Berlin Brandenburg,
so ein regionaler Medienverein und der vierte ist dann Eco, Verband der Internetwirtschaft, das sind die Provider.
Und die mussten sich auf eine Person einigen und mich haben dann Leute gefragt, könnte ich mir vorstellen, das zu machen?
Ich habe dann mal nachgeschaut, was macht der Fernsehrat so?
Und dann habe ich gefragt, naja könnt ihr überhaupt einen Österreicher da rein nominieren?
Und da haben die gesagt, wissen wir auch nicht und dann haben sie recherchiert und es steht nirgends „keine Ausländer“
oder „keine nichtdeutschen Staatsbürger“, also Staatsbürgerschaft ist nicht entscheidend.
Also was nicht explizit verboten ist, ist in Deutschland ja noch erlaubt.
Immerhin.
Dann wurde ich da rein nominiert.
Und ich glaube, einer der Gründe, warum ich gefragt wurde, war, dass ich schon 2013 mal ein White Paper für D64 geschrieben habe,
das sich beschäftigt hat mit Creative Commons im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk.
Und so viele Nerds, die sich halt irgendwie so mit Internet und öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk beschäftigen, gab es dann offenbar auch nicht.
Und ja, seit vier Jahren bin ich jetzt da knapp Mitglied.
Habe da in der Zeit sehr viel über öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gelernt und mich auf zwei Dinge vor allem fokussiert.
Einerseits wollte ich diese Gremien transparenter machen.
Also wenn ich da schon für das Internet im Fernsehrat sitze, dann schreibe ich auch ins Internet über den Fernsehrat.
Das mache ich exzessiv, würde ich sagen, bei Netzpolitik.org, da habe ich eine Reihe „Neues aus dem Fernsehrat“
und 55 Blogeinträge in den letzten drei Jahren da geschrieben.
Und das hat auch schon für durchaus einiges – das wäre ein Thema für einen eigenen Podcast – an Diskussionen gesorgt,
weil ich ja zum Beispiel aus Freundeskreissitzungen berichtet habe, wenn da Vorwahlen stattfinden und so.
Ja und das andere Thema, was mir wirklich ein Anliegen ist, ist halt,
wie kann man den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk auch organisatorisch neu aufstellen für das digitale Zeitalter,
für Plattformöffentlichkeiten im Netz?
Werden wir sicherlich auch nochmal zu kommen.
Vielleicht so als letztes Vorgeplänkel, wir sitzen jetzt hier in den Räumen des Momentum Instituts, eine, wie sie sich selbst nennt, Denkfabrik.
Also das schöne deutsche Wort für ThinkTank, was in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen ziviler klingt auch.
Was ist das?
Ja, also eigentlich habe ich, als ich 2005/06 nach Deutschland gegangen bin, so die nicht komplett alle Verbindungen zu Österreich gekappt,
das lag einerseits an meiner Partnerin, mit der ich inzwischen zwei Kinder habe, die quasi in Österreich geblieben ist damals
und der andere Grund, ich war politisch aktiv auch in Österreich schon und habe damals dann mit anderen gemeinsam 2007/08 den Momentum Congress gegründet.
Den gibt es jetzt seit über 13 Jahren, der findet einmal im Jahr in Hallstatt, also im Weltkulturerbe, diesen Ort, den die Chinesen nachgebaut haben, statt.
Und die Idee ist da gewesen, Leute aus Politik, Zivilgesellschaft und Wissenschaft zusammenzubringen, bewusst irgendwo abgelegen in den Bergen,
um mal quasi sie rauszunehmen.
Also Momentum hat so diese Doppelbedeutung, einerseits einen Moment Auszeit von dem Alltag,
um mal wirklich tiefgehender auf Basis von Beiträgen, alle die dort teilnehmen haben einen Beitrag, zu diskutieren.
Man ist da zwei Tage zusammen in einer kleinen Gruppe, die zu ähnlichen Themen arbeitet, aber aus diesen unterschiedlichen drei Bereichen kommt.
Bewusst kein Zweck, also da werden keine Anträge verabschiedet, man muss sich auf nichts einigen.
Das Ziel ist wirklich, da klüger rauszugehen als man reingeht.
Aber schon mit einer weltanschaulich progressiven Schlagseite, also in Deutschland irgendwo rot-rot-grün-plus Umfeld würde ich sagen.
Und das hatten wir vor 13 Jahren oder eigentlich recht bald hat sich rausgestellt, das ist nett und das ist gut, das trägt zur Vernetzung bei,
inzwischen waren da über 3000 Leute, aber es ist trotzdem der Transmissionsriemen in die Gesellschaft und in noch vielleicht Politik der fehlt ein bisschen.
Und das zweite, was wir beobachtet haben, ist, dass es halt einen Gründungsboom gab von liberalen rechtskonservativen ThinkTanks im deutschen Sprachraum auch.
Also in Deutschland kennt man da vielleicht die Initiative neuer sozialer Marktwirtschaft, finanziert von den Arbeitgebern.
In Österreich finde ich noch besser eigentlich aufgestellt als die Initiative neuer sozialer Marktwirtschaft ist das Pendant so ein bisschen die Agenda Austria,
die von allen Industriellen, die es so in Österreich gibt, finanziert wird.
Die eigentlich den gesellschaftlichen Diskurs recht stark schaffen zu beeinflussen über mediale Präsenz,
über kontinuierliche ThinkTank-Arbeit eben.
Und da war immer schon die Überlegung, eigentlich müsste man dem was entgegensetzen.
Gleichzeitig ist aber das Problem, ThinkTank ist ein sehr elitäres Konzept, da sind die klugen Köpfe, die setzen sich irgendwo hin
und die denken das aus und über mediale Kontakte wird dann versucht, Einfluss zu nehmen auf die Meinungshegemonie, wenn man den Begriff hier so nennen kann.
Und wir haben gedacht, wir müssen das irgendwie ein bisschen anders machen.
Also wenn man sagt, das kann man nicht eins zu eins kopieren, weil das wäre einfach so ein elitärer Ansatz, der würde nicht passen zu einem vielleicht progressiveren Projekt.
Und deshalb haben wir uns als Anspruch, ob wir den erfüllen, auch eigentlich den Untertitel gegeben, ThinkTank der Vielen
und womit wir das leben wollen ist halt, dass wir sagen, einerseits ist das ein Anspruch, an dem wir uns messen lassen wollen
und andererseits sagen wir aber, wir sind ein Hybrid, es gibt so einerseits einen Teil, der wirklich längerfristig an so Studien arbeitet,
versucht Dinge zu erheben, Daten zu erheben, Fragen zu beantworten, die zu kurz kommen,
aber andererseits haben wir Moment.at auch ein tagesaktuelles Medium, das sich unmittelbar an die Vielen richtet.
Und wo wir sagen, wir wollen einerseits Dinge, die wir selbst machen, damit übersetzen in einfache Sprache,
wo wir aber auch sagen, die digitalen Möglichkeiten sind heute da, dass man unmittelbar eigentlich an eine breit Öffentlichkeit sich wenden kann.
Und gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch ein Fundraising-Tool, wir sagen, ThinkTank der Vielen funktioniert nur, wenn viele da quasi zumindest vielleicht mit kleinen Beiträgen auch mit zahlen.
Und wir finanzieren uns derzeit zu einem Drittel kleinkleinst Spenden, ein Drittel Großspenden und ein Drittel aus einer gewerkschaftsnahen Stiftung.
Aber wir nehmen kein Geld zum Beispiel von Parteien.
Und wir nehmen auch keine Auftragsforschung.
Also wir sagen ganz bewusst, wer unsere Arbeit gut findet, wir freuen uns über Unterstützung,
aber wir nehmen keine Aufträge an, das würde dem unabhängigen Anspruch eines ThinkTanks nicht entsprechen.
Und das ist vielleicht noch wichtig, ich mache das ehrenamtlich.
Also ich bin der wissenschaftliche Leiter, ich habe das mitgegründet mit Barbara Blaha, die Vollzeit, die ist quasi all in gegangen,
die war zehn Jahre in einem Verlag, hat dort das Sachbuchprogramm geleitet, war früher mal Vorsitzende der österreichischen Hochschülerschaft.
Das ist in Österreich ein bisschen professioneller wie in Deutschland, da gibt es ja keinen Bundesstudierendenparlament, in Österreich gibt es das.
Da war sie die Chefin.
Und sie macht das quasi jetzt Vollzeit.
Ist auch das Gesicht, nach außen stärker vielleicht noch als ich.
Und meine Aufgabe sehe ich eher darin, wirklich auch zu sagen, wir sagen zwar klar wo wir stehen, wir haben Haltungen,
aber das bedeutet nicht, dass wir wissenschaftliche Standards nicht erfüllen wollen, sondern das ist quasi eine Grundvoraussetzung,
um auch glaubwürdig langfristig hier irgendwie gute Argumente machen zu können.
Aber sozusagen ich habe meine Professur in Innsbruck dafür nicht aufgegeben.
Ich pendle sowieso zwischen Wien und Innsbruck und bin halt jetzt so ungefähr zwei Tage die Woche hier im Büro in Wien
und den Rest der Woche in Innsbruck.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall genug Spielraum, um die eigenen Organisationstheorien auch wirklich praktisch zur Anwendung zu bringen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Würde ich sagen, dass mir das immer wichtig war.
Also ich glaube, einerseits mache ich an der Uni, das hört sich immer so absurd an, wenn ich das wem erzähle,
aber ich würde wirklich sagen, in der BWL mache ich eher Grundlagenforschung.
Ich bin BWLer, aber mich interessieren so Grundfarben von, was ist in der Organisation oder wie macht es Sinn, eine Organisation sich vorzustellen?
Was ist noch eine Organisation, was ist keine mehr?
Wie kann ich eben zum Beispiel Identität stabilisieren?
Wie bilden sich Organisationen auch imagent heraus?
Das ist alles eher so Grundlagenforschung.
Genau.
Und genau da will ich dann auch mal einsteigen wollen, um vielleicht erst mal so ein paar Begrifflichkeiten auch mal festzuhalten.
Und will wissen, worüber wir reden.
Jetzt ist natürlich dieser Begriff Organisation schon recht schwammig.
Wenn man Organisationsforschung macht, was sind denn dann diese Organisationen?
Also auf was, ist das jetzt alles, was irgendwie mehr als eine Person ist oder gibt es irgendwie ein bestimmtes Charakteristikum,
wo man sagen kann, ab dann ist es auch organisiert und wert, auch mal entsprechend erforscht zu werden?
Ich glaube, du weißt gar nicht, wie sehr ich mich über diese Frage freue,
weil das wirklich ein Thema ist, das mich umtreibt, zu dem ich auch mit Kollegen gerade wirklich unmittelbar forsche,
drüber nachdenke, diskutiere und obwohl die Organisationsforschung jetzt keine junge Disziplin ist,
im Gegenteil, man kann sagen, Organisations- und Managementforschung geht zurück bis zum Taylorismus Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts.
Taylorismus meint, dass man ganz … also das lief damals unter Scientific-Management, also wissenschaftliches Management,
dass man versucht, Arbeitsprozesse ganz genau aufzuzeichnen und dann ideal zu optimieren
und so quasi die Effizienz von Unternehmen zu steigern.
Frederick Winslow Taylor hat das begründet.
Genau, nach dem ist das benannt.
Heute gibt es viele Diskussionen darüber, ob wir im Zeitalter des Neotaylorismus leben, weil heute ja, wenn man sich einen Amazon Lagermitarbeiter anschaut,
der quasi komplett überwacht wird, mit GPS getrackt wird, jede Klopause wird quasi von dem übernommen und dann wird feingesteuert
und wenn er quasi zu langsam ist, dann kann der Supervisor ihm quasi über Bluetooth-Device ins Ohr sagen, schneller Junge.
Also das erinnert dann schon sehr gruselig an die Anfänge des Scientific-Managements, wenn man so will.
Aber so zurück zu dieser Frage, wo soll man die Grenze ziehen?
Also natürlich jede Definition in wissenschaftlichen Kontexten ist mal eine Konvention.
Die Frage, was ist, hat Popper gesagt, ist eigentlich keine wissenschaftlich beantwortbare.
Ich kann mich darauf einigen, dass wir, wenn wir über Organisationen sprechen, das so oder so definieren,
damit wir wissen, dass wir vom selben reden.
Aber da gibt es natürlich solche und solche Definitionen und in der Organisationsforschung ist das gar nicht mal so klar.
Also da gibt es eigentlich zwei starke Strömungen.
Die einen die sagen, wir müssen das sehr eng halten und Organisation ist eigentlich vor allem formale Organisation
und das ist etwas, was von Dauer ist, was eine Stabilität aufweist.
Und das geht weiter darüber hinaus, über das, was irgendwie so zwei Freunde, die irgendwas verabreden.
Also ich sage mal so ein Beispiel, drei Leute, die sich verabreden, gemeinsam beim Umziehen zu helfen, die sind auch organisiert,
die organisieren auch, wer trägt was, vielleicht machen sie, wenn sie mehr Leute sind, sogar irgendwie eine Kette, um die Dinge runterzutragen,
aber man würde nicht sagen, das ist eine Organisation.
Es ist quasi, die sind organisiert, das ist eine Gruppe vielleicht noch, und ich würde sagen, einer der großen Unterschiede da ist,
oder was müsste passieren, dass die eine Organisation werden?
Und ich würde sagen, einer der entscheidenden Punkte ist, dass sie eine soziale Adresse quasi etablieren,
das heißt, dass sie nicht mehr eben als die Gruppe mit ihren den Einzelnamen angesprochen werden,
sondern dass man die Organisation als Organisation, dass man ihr eigentlich eine Art Akteurscharakter zuschreibt.
Und das haben zum Beispiel ganz klar eine Universität hat eine asoziale Adresse, ist übrigens die freie Universität Berlin
oder die Universität Innsbruck, die sind auch als Organisationen präsent, die haben Organe,
die für diese Organisation aber unterschreiben.
Da ist es eindeutig, bei Unternehmen dasselbe.
Also bei formalen Organisationen ist das immer erfüllt oder meistens.
Dann gibt es ja Grenzfälle, wie ist das mit einer digitalen Gemeinschaft?
Ist die Linux-Community, ist das schon eine Organisation?
Ich würde sagen, tendenziell hat das schon starken organisationalen Charakter, die Regeln sind da teilweise sogar niedergeschrieben.
Auch wenn sie jetzt vielleicht nicht rechtlich bindend sind, aber da sind sehr starke Pfadabhängigkeiten auch vorhanden,
die das Ganze stabilisieren.
Und man spricht auch der Linux-Community teilweise eine eigene Akteurseigenschaft zu.
Man sagt ja, die Linux-Community will das nicht, das ist oftmals so, dass man von der Community spricht, obwohl es die so ja gar nicht gibt, wie wir wissen.
Bzw. schwer zu definieren ist, wo sie anfangen würde und wo sie auch endet.
Genau, wobei man sagen muss, an den Grenzen ist das bei Organisationen ja immer gar nicht so einfach, also wer da noch dazu gehört.
Also das ist auch ein altes Thema.
Also Krankenhaus, wer gehört zur Organisation, wer ist Teil der Organisation und wer nicht?
Also okay Ärzte und Pflegekräfte klar, Verwaltungspersonal auch noch klar.
Wie ist das mit Leuten, die dort stationär untergebracht sind?
Sind das Kunden, sind die Teil der Organisation?
Also was ist mit Patientensprechern oder so?
Und ich würde sagen im digitalen Zeitalter werden diese Grenzen teilweise noch stärker aufgeweicht.
Also früher war es okay, der Kunde ist klar, der nimmt die Produkte und Dienstleistungen in Anspruch und dafür bezahlt er oder sie.
Heute, wenn man das oftmals sieht, dass man sagt, ja diese Kunden sollen auch Teil unseres Innovationsprozesses werden,
wir machen User Innovation oder eben noch stärker bei so OpenSource-Projekten, wo quasi Leute mitentwickeln,
freiwillige Programmiererinnen und Programmierer, die nie Teil der Organisation waren, aber wesentlich zum Produkt beitragen,
das eine Organisation zum Beispiel vermarktet.
Sind die dann Teil der Organisation?
Also auf jeden Fall sind sie sehr wichtig für die Organisation und man versuchen, auch diese Beziehungen zu diese informalen Gemeinschaften zu managen.
Also ich würde sagen, es gibt eine zweite Strömung, ich habe es erwähnt, in der Organisationsforschung, die sagt,
diese Grenze lässt sich nicht ziehen, deshalb lassen wir das gleich.
Die sprechen lieber vom Organisieren.
Die sagen, wir schauen uns alle Prozesse an, wo organisiert wird, ob das dann im Rahmen einer formalen Organisation passiert
oder ob das zum Beispiel einfach ist, ich organisiere eine soziale Bewegung zum Beispiel.
Fridays for Future.
Fridays for Future, wie organisieren die sich, wie treffen die Entscheidungen?
Wer es ganz klar definiert hat war Niklas Luhmann, der hat eine klare Grenze gezogen für Organisationen.
Und der hat es genau an diesem Punkt der Entscheidung festgemacht.
Also Luhmann sagt, soziale Systeme bestehen aus Kommunikation und Organisationen sind auch soziale Systeme,
aber was Organisationen von allen anderen sozialen Systemen abgrenzbar macht oder was sie davon unterscheidet ist die Möglichkeit
von kollektiv bindenden Entscheidungen, also quasi Entscheidungskommunikation.
das ist etwas, was Organisationen von anderen sozialen Gebilden und Phänomenen unterscheidet.
Und ich finde, das ist eine sehr kluge Unterscheidung und ich würde sagen, das ist die, die mir noch am einleuchtendsten erscheint soweit.
Um das an Beispielen deutlich zu machen, Fridays for Future ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Die Bewegung Fridays for Future die kann nichts entscheiden als Bewegung.
Jeder kann sagen, ich mach da jetzt Fridays for Future, ich mach da eine Demo, ich mache einen Infostand.
Führt dann auch zu Problemen, da machen Leute mit, die will man vielleicht gar nicht dabei haben,
aber es gibt natürlich Organisationen, die im Rahmen von Fridays for Future entstanden sind.
Irgendwer hat eine Webseite eingerichtet, irgendwer bezahlt die Rechnungen dieser Webseite.
Das sind dann Vereine und man könnte sagen, Greenpeace oder so ist ja auch ein bisschen Teil dieser Umweltklimabewegung,
aber niemand würde sagen, Greenpeace oder andere NGOs können für die gesamte Bewegung Entscheidungen treffen.
Aber Greenpeace als Organisation kann natürlich entscheiden, wir melden eine Webseite an, wir melden eine Demo an.
Das sind quasi Entscheidungen, die Greenpeace als Organisation treffen kann, aber nicht die Bewegung.
Für die Bewegung kann keiner was entscheiden.
Im Staat ähnlich.
Also als Gesellschaft können wir nichts entscheiden, aber es gibt einen Staat, wo quasi Politikerinnen und Politiker gewählt werden,
die dann im Rahmen dessen Entscheidungen treffen können.
Also der Staat ist eine Organisation, die Gesellschaft ist keine Organisation, die Gesellschaft ist mehr.
In der Gesellschaft gibt es viele Organisationen, aber die Gesellschaft als Ganzes kann nichts entscheiden.
Abgesehen von Wahlen, aber da könnte man auch nochmal drüber diskutieren.
Aber Wahlen sind in der politischen Organisation.
Und man merkt ja auch, da dürfen nur bestimmte Leute mitbestimmen.
Also in Wien zum Beispiel ist es besonders krass, da bewegen wir uns in Richtung 30-40% der Menschen, die hier ständig leben, dürfen nicht wählen.
Also Österreich hat ein besonders restriktives Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht und gleichzeitig kommen immer mehr Leute,
in den letzten Jahren auch, wandern zu und das heißt, EU-Bürger dürfen halt okay auf Bezirksebene wählen,
aber auf Landesebene in Wien, Wien ist ja auch so wie Berlin Bundesland und Gemeinde gleichzeitig.
Also ich würde sagen, das merkt man schon, da wird eine Grenze gezogen, das ist die Staatsbürgerschaft
und die Staatsbürger entscheiden wiederum darüber, ob diese Grenze so bleibt oder weitergezogen wird.
Also da merkt man, das politische System ist ein organisiertes System.
Der Staat ist eine Organisation, aber die Gesellschaft, wo diese Menschen ja alle Teil davon sind, die kann da nicht wählen, kann da nicht mitentscheiden.
Bewegung schafft Organisation.
Jetzt bist du ja unter anderem auch über die Betriebswirtschaftslehre eingestiegen und ich würde sagen,
da steht nun vollkommen außer Frage, dass man in dem Bereich der Firmen und überhaupt der ganzen Wirtschaft natürlich die meisten und mit stärksten Organisationsformen,
also am stärksten als Organisation ausgeprägte Organisationsformen findet so.
Firmen, GmbHs, AGs, etc., da ist ja auch rechtlich sehr viel festgelegt.
Das ist ja nun sicherlich auch Teil der Forschung.
Aber dann gibt es ja auch sehr viele andere mittlerweile etablierte Organisationsformen, GOs, also vom Staat gegründete oder vom Staat getragene Organisationen.
Was weiß ich, Raumfahrtorganisationen etc., aber eben auch dieser große NGO-Bereich.
Welcher dieser Bereiche hat jetzt in deiner Arbeit da am meisten Interesse auf sich gezogen oder ist von sich aus vielleicht auch am interessantesten,
um überhaupt erst mal auf Dinge zu kommen?
Also die klassische Organisationsforschung war eben eine betriebswirtschaftliche Forschung,
das heißt, da ging es wirklich um Betriebe und Betriebe und ihre Abläufe zu optimieren.
Das Schöne ist, in der deutschsprachigen BWL gibt es da eine Tradition, die war ursprünglich so in der Zwischenkriegszeit,
der Begründer der deutschsprachigen Betriebswirtschaftslehre – ich kann das nicht ohne Nuscheln sagen,
ich bitte um Verzeihung – war Eugen Schmalenbach zum Beispiel, der hat damals aber das sehr stark auch als Beitrag zum Gemeinwohl verstanden.
Also so die Idee, es geht nicht darum, die Gewinnmaximierung es Unternehmers irgendwie zu unterstützen mit wissenschaftlichen Mitteln,
sondern Betriebe effizienter zu gestalten, damit quasi unsere Ressourcen auch bestmöglich genutzt werden und wir als Gesellschaft mehr Wohlstand haben.
Das war so das Selbstverständnis.
Nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg hat sich das ein bisschen davon verabschiedet.
Man hat diese Gemeinwohlorientierung eher aufgegeben und aber gleichzeitig schon stark den Betrieb ins Zentrum gestellt.
Man muss sich vor Augen halten, das war damals 50er Jahre Systemkonkurrenz,
also die BWLer haben sich natürlich gefragt, braucht es uns im Sozialismus?
Es war ja noch nicht klar, welches der beiden Systeme sich durchsetzt.
Und die Antwort war natürlich ja.
Also Gutenberg, der Neubegründer, wenn man so will, der BWL nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg,
hat deshalb unterschieden zwischen wirtschaftssystemabhängigen und -unabhängigen Faktoren,
die eine Rolle spielen bei Betrieben und hat gemeint, naja also das Autonomieprinzip, dass der, dem die Produktionsmittel gehören,
alleine entscheidet, wie der Betrieb geführt wird, gibt es halt in der Marktwirtschaft.
Im Kommunismus ist das halt das Prinzip der plandeterminierten Leistungserbringung.
Aber in beiden Fällen geht es darum, dass man einen Betrieb hat, der möglichst effizient aus Inputs Outputs erzeugt.
Also egal, ob ich im Kommunismus bin oder in der Marktwirtschaft, BWLer braucht es.
Sozusagen damit waren wir als Disziplin save.
Genau, und erst, würde ich sagen, in den 70er Jahren, als die deutschsprachige BWL sich stärker international geöffnet hat,
hat man sich von diesem stark produktionsorientierten Input-Output Optimierungsverständnis hin geöffnet
und hat, also wir sprechen da, also in meiner Einführungsvorlesung, ich habe die Einführungsvorlesung auch in Innsbruck,
wo alle, die dort BWL anfragen zu studieren, müssen zuerst mal durch mich und einen Kollegen durch,
dann erkläre ich immer, ich nenne das immer, die sozialwissenschaftliche Öffnung.
Also man hat quasi stärker weg von nur, wir sagen jetzt wie es richtig geht, wir erklären euch Praktikern jetzt mal, wie ihr das machen sollt,
damit ihr effizienter agiert, in Richtung, bevor wir überhaupt mal Ratschläge geben, sollten wir vielleicht noch rausfinden,
wie es überhaupt funktioniert, was da überhaupt in den Organisationen passiert und man hat den Blick geweitet über Betriebe
und über Unternehmen hinweg zu anderen Organisationen, die ja aber auch natürlich für Betriebe total relevant sind.
Die von dir angesprochenen staatlichen Behörden, aber natürlich auch eben diese NGOs, die auch da in den 70er Jahren mit Umweltbewegungen
zum ersten Mal so für Unternehmen unbequem wurden.
Oder natürlich der Klassiker und das gab es natürlich schon lange vor der Umweltbewegung, Gewerkschaften.
Und da ist schon interessant, dass das halt im deutschsprachigen Raum spielten Gewerkschaften in der BWL kaum eine Rolle.
Die hatten irgendwie keinen Platz, das waren wenn dann Störfaktoren.
Während es im angelsächsischen Bereich immer schon zum Beispiel so was gab, das heißt dort, industrial relations,
also industrielle Beziehungen.
Und das heißt, da hat man immer schon stärker im Blick, dass quasi auch Gewerkschaften, Arbeitnehmer- und Arbeitnehmerinnenorganisationen
eine Rollen spielen dafür auch und das Verhältnis zwischen quasi den Unternehmern und Unternehmerinnen und den Gewerkschaften
ist entscheidend auch dafür, ob man effizient quasi produzieren, Leistungen erbringen kann.
Und das ist auch, quasi selbst wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich Gewerkschaften gar nicht gut finde, ist es wichtig, sich mit dem Phänomen zu beschäftigen.
Ja und das hat sich eben immer weiter geöffnet und jetzt geht es eben durchaus auch um Fragen, die mit Unternehmen nur noch am Rande zu tun haben.
Also einer meiner Forschungsschwerpunkte war zum Beispiel auch die Wikipedia, wo man eben die Frage stellt,
wie organisiert man so eine freie Enzyklopädie des Weltwissens?
Hat was mit Freiwilligenorganisation zu tun, hat was zu tun mit Qualitätskontrolle, Qualitätssicherung
und genau auch mit dem Verhältnis von formaler Organisation zu informaler Gemeinschaft.
Also wenn ich jetzt das Wikimedia Fundation, die quasi ja die Betreiberin, nicht mal seit Beginn, da können wir vielleicht noch drüber reden,
der Wikipedia war, wenn ich will, dass meine Community sich gut entwickelt, wie kann ich denn das tun?
Ich kann denen ja keine Weisungen erteilen, das sind lauter Freiwillige.
Also wenn ich will, dass da eben, ein Thema, was die Wikipedia jetzt seit zehn Jahren umtreibt oder die Wikimedia,
wenn alle Studien immer ergeben, dass nur zwischen 10 und 20 Prozent meiner Freiwilligen Frauen sind,
ich aber den Anspruch habe, das Weltwissen zu sammeln, dann kann man sich schon denken,
okay da werden bestimmte Themen nicht so gut behandelt oder dann gibt es auf bestimmte Themen eine stärker männliche Perspektive.
Aber das Problem ist, wie kriege ich denn das gelöst?
Einem Unternehmen sage ich, ihr habt zu wenig Frauen im Aufsichtsrat, na gut, dann bestelle ich mehr Frauen in den Aufsichtsrat.
Oder ich habe zu wenig Frauen in der Abteilung, dann stelle ich mehr Frauen ein.
Ich weiß, das ist auch nicht so leicht, also gerade in Branchen, wo halt einfach weniger Frauen überhaupt diese Ausbildungen abschließen,
ist es ganz schwer, den Anteil zu erhöhen, aber zumindest ist das eine Option.
Aber bei einer Organisation wie der Wikimedia und der Wikipedia, wo alle Leute, die die Inhalte dort schreiben, das freiwillig machen,
selbstmotiviert hinkommen, wie kann ich das denn dann lösen?
Bleiben wir vielleicht erst mal bei den Organisationen, die jetzt so zumindest von sich behaupten, eine klare Struktur zu haben.
Ja.
Du hast jetzt einige genannt, die Firmen, die GOs, die NGOs, die Gewerkschaften.
Mir würde jetzt noch was anderes einfallen, was vielleicht da noch mit reingenommen werden soll, die Parteien.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht, wenn man jetzt diese klassischen Strukturen sich mal anschaut, dann vereint die ja sozusagen immer dieses Prinzip,
dass sie eigentlich durch eine Hierarchie geprägt sind.
Es gibt dann immer ein mehr oder weniger klares Oben, da gibt es so die COs, die Chefs, die Präsidenten, halt die Großkopferten,
die halt in irgendeiner Form die Macht in sich versammeln, natürlich auch die Verantwortung, im besten Fall zumindest,
ob sie die dann wahrnehmen, andere Frage.
Und darunter hat man dann eben so sein Org-Chart und es gibt immer mal wieder nochmal eine Ebene darunter
und der Aufstieg bedeutet halt, oben irgendwie in diesem Org-Chart anzukommen, wo sich dann eben irgendwie alles ausdünnt.
Also ist das so eine Erkenntnis aus der Geschichte, dass man sagt, ja genau so muss das auch sein, nur so funktionieren Menschen in einer Organisation?
Man kann nicht anders arbeiten, als dass es sich nach oben immer weiter verjüngt und im Zweifelsfall bei einer einzelnen verantwortlichen Person hängenbleibt.
Oder weicht das in irgendeiner Form auf oder hat sich das einfach als so resistent ergeben, liegt das in der Natur der Menschen?
Was führt dazu, dass es so ist?
Also ich wäre prinzipiell mal vorsichtig, vom Sein auf das Sollen zu schließen.
Also diesen naturalistischen Fehlschluss gibt es in allen Disziplinen.
Nur weil es so ist, heißt es nicht, dass es so sein soll oder muss oder so.
Ja guck mal, man könnte ja sagen, hat sich evolutionär so ergeben, dann spricht vielleicht was dafür.
Obwohl ich durchaus Evolutionsökonomie einen interessanten Ansatz finde,
und da glaube ich, dass zum Beispiel mehr uns verrät darüber, wie unser Wirtschaftssystem sich entwickelt als klassische, neoklassische ökonomische Ansätze,
aber jenseits dessen wäre ich da sehr vorsichtig, von einer Zwangsläufigkeit zu sprechen.
Ich bin eh ein großer Fan der Kontingenz, also des so aber auch anders möglich seins.
Also es mag sein, dass eine bestimmte Organisationsform gut funktioniert und so,
aber es heißt erstens nicht, dass nicht eine andere Organisationsform genauso gut oder sogar besser funktionieren könnte
und dann ist immer auch schon bei dieser Frage, gut für wen, besser für wen?
Also für wen funktioniert eine bestimmte Organisationsform gut?
Und das können dann Einzelpersonen sein.
Also man merkt es ja selbst in den Unternehmen.
So Diktatur funktioniert super für Diktatoren.
Zum Beispiel oder auch für die Günstlinge, zumindest solange sie Günstlinge bleiben.
Und solange sich ihre Präferenzen nicht ändern und solange sie halt bestimmte Weltbilder vertreten und so weiter.
Also diese Frage, für wen funktioniert etwas, jede Frage nach gut oder schlecht ist eine immer normativ politische Frage
und das betrifft auch die BWL, das betrifft sogar die BWL-Bereiche, die die Leute vielleicht sogar am meisten mit der BWL verbinden,
wo sie aber gleichzeitig denken, das ist das langweiligste, damit will ich nichts zu tun haben, wie zum Beispiel Accounting, Rechnungswesen, Buchhaltung.
Wo man sich denkt, ja da wird ja nur aufgeschrieben was ist, aber aufschreiben was ist und die Logik, in der man Dinge aufschreibt,
hat natürlich auch krasse Verteilungskonsequenzen.
Also zum Beispiel je nachdem wie ich Gemeinkosten, die ja per Definition nicht zurechenbar sind auf einzelne Abteilungen,
die werden dann umgelegt, da gibt es Verteilungsschlüssel.
Und das kann dann dazu führen, dass einzelne Abteilungen schlechter oder besser aussteigen und wenn es darum geht,
okay wir müssen sparen, wo wird wer rausgeworfen in welcher Abteilung?
Dann würden sie sagen, ihr macht zu wenig Deckungsbeitrag oder so.
Ja, also diese Rechnung, diese ganz langweiligen buchhalterischen Kostenrechnungen, die sind aus Unternehmensperspektive hochpolitisch
und haben Folgen dafür, wo wird eingespart, wann wird überhaupt eingespart, wer muss entlassen werden oder nicht
oder muss überhaupt wer entlassen werden?
Das heißt, insofern finde ich, muss man da sehr vorsichtig sein mit, das muss so sein.
Aber du hast ja vor allem auf die Hierarchie als Frage abgestimmt.
Also es gibt in der Organisationsforschung sogar Theorieansätze, die würden anders als Luhmann nicht die Entscheidung ins Zentrum stellen,
sondern die würden die Hierarchie ins Zentrum stellen.
Die sagen dann, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen marktlicher Organisation von etwas und hierarchischer Organisation.
Da spricht man zwischen Markt und Hierarchie und die entscheidende Frage, die dieser Ansatz hat, das ist der Transaktionskostenansatz,
sich stellt ist immer, soll ich etwas selbst hierarchisch organisieren oder soll ich etwas outsourcen, quasi make oder buy.
Mach ich es selber oder kaufe ich es?
Und das hat man dann schon bald verändert zu, make, buy or network.
Also mache ich es selber, kaufe ich es zu oder mache ich es nicht selber, gebe es aber auch nicht irgendwie so an den freien Markt mit einer Ausschreibung,
sondern gehe ich eine längerfristige Austauschbeziehung mit einem Partner ein, der einfach gut ist
und damit es nicht nur marktlich, aber es ist auch nicht komplett Teil der Hierarchie.
Und damit kommen wir schon zu dem Punkt, wo du sagst, muss das so sein?
Also ich würde sagen, es gibt schon eine Tendenz dazu, wenn ich Dinge arbeitsteilig organisiere und dann wieder koordiniere,
dass zumindest informelle Hierarchien sich ausbilden, einfach über die Zeit.
Also selbst wenn alle mit gleichen Ressourcen starten, dann ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es über die Zeit zu Umverteilungen kommt,
die dann wiederum einen Einfluss darauf haben, wie das weiter in der Zukunft organisiert wird.
Und da ist es oft so, dass Dinge entstehen, die hierarchischen Charakter haben.
Und ich würde sagen, das betrifft aber eben nicht nur formale Organisationen, das betrifft auf zum Beispiel Communitys,
die ja sagen, ja Communitys sind definitionsgemäß so, alle sind gleich, also eine Gemeinschaft von gleichen.
Es hat keiner eine formale Führungsrolle in der Community, aber wenn man dann anschaut, wie Communitys in der Praxis funktionieren,
da gibt es dann oft meritokratische Elemente, also meritokratisch heißt, die Leute, die halt mehr beigetragen haben, mehr leisten,
mehr Zeit auch haben, auch die Gelegenheit hatten, mehr Zeit einzubringen, ja die haben halt dann oft mehr zu sagen.
Wer macht hat recht und so.
Zum Beispiel ja oder ich meine …
Oder das Modell des Benevolent Dictators.
Ja, ich meine, das kommt dann noch dazu, dass auch bei so Communitys dann teilweise am Ende gibt es dann eine Variante
oder wo man sagen muss, da kommt die Hierarchie eigentlich über die Marke rein.
Also das muss jetzt nicht mal markenrechtlich geschützt sein, aber bei Linux ist es so, jeder kann den Code nehmen wie er ist heute,
forken und ein anderes Linux bauen, machen auch immer wieder Leute.
Dasselbe wäre auch zum Beispiel bei der Wikipedia möglich.
Die Wikipedia steht auch unter einer Lizenz, die sogar nach dem Vorbild von OpenSource Lizenzen quasi entwickelt wurde,
und ich kann heute hergehen, alles, was die Freiwilligen in der Wikipedia in den letzten knapp 20 Jahren da zusammengetragen haben,
nehmen und die Leopedia machen und sagen, jetzt mach ich da weiter, weil ihr macht das falsch.
Kann ich schon, das Problem ist, ich bin dann halt auf einmal alleine mit Millionen von Artikeln in zig Sprachen,
also dass das dann weiterhin aktuell bleibt, da bräuchte ich Leute, die mit mir machen und die müsste ich halt dann da überzeugen.
Und da muss man sagen, das ist schwer.
Also es gibt immer wieder mal Versuche, es gab in der Geschichte der Wikipedia sogar eine derartige Spaltung,
einen sogenannte Forke, der recht erfolgreich war, und zwar war das 2003.
Da haben sich die spanischsprechenden Wikipedianer abgespalten und die Enciclopedia Libre Universal en Español gegründet.
Hatten dann auch die Mehrheit der spanischen Community mit sich.
Warum?
Der Hintergrund war, damals gab es die Wikimedia Foundation noch nicht.
Das wissen die wenigsten heute, die Wikipedia wurde ja gegründet, das wissen alle, von Jimmy Wales und Larry Sanger,
aber wer hatte die Markenrechte eigentlich ursprünglich an der Wikipedia und wo waren die Server?
Die standen im Keller von Bomis.com.
Und wer das jetzt nachschaut, die Wikipedia hat natürlich einen super Artikel über die Geschichte der Wikipedia,
da steht auch das mit Bomis drinnen.
Bomis.com war so eine Firma, wo Jimmy Wales einer von vier Gründern war, und deren Geschäftsmodell war,
anzeigenfinanzierte Suchmaschine für erotische Inhalte, Zielgruppe Männer.
Also soll noch einer sagen, dass nichts gutes aus irgendwie so Pornogeschäftsmodellen entstehen kann.
Und die hatten quasi genug Serverkapazitäten, um da am Anfang diese Newpedia, so hieß das am Anfang und dann Wikipedia da zu hosten
und denen hat halt quasi eigentlich dann, das ist abgehoben, ohne dass die das erwartet haben, und auf einmal war Wikipedia wertvoll,
die Marke sehr wertvoll und das lief aber immer noch auf dem Server von Bomis.
Und da gab es den Benevolent Dictator Jimmy Wales.
Und die spanischsprachigen Wikipedianer dachten sich so und der Jimmy Wales eben, der hatte keine Skrupel irgendwie,
der fand Anzeigen nicht problematisch.
Und viele Wikipedianer sagten aber, also wir machen da die ganze Arbeit, wir wollen jetzt nicht, dass irgendwer,
Jimmy Wales oder sonstwer herkommt, dem halt gerade Bomis.com gehört und sagt, und jetzt kleistern wir das mit Anzeigen voll
und wir verdienen dann an eurer freiwilligen Arbeit, das wollen wir nicht, deshalb spalten wir uns ab.
Und das war, glaube ich, so einer der letzten Trigger, warum dann man die Foundation gegründet hat als gemeinnützige Trägerorganisation
und die hat dann auch von Jimmy Wales dann die Markenrechte übertragen bekommen und die betreibt heute die Server,
die entwickelt heute die Software.
Und da merkt man schon, ja, dass so Regeln und so die Frage von, wer verfügt über kritische Ressourcen, in dem Fall,
wer kann über eine Marke bestimmen, dass es das auch in Kontexten gibt, wo jetzt formal eigentlich gar nicht eine große Hierarchie vielleicht man erkennen würde.
Aber trotzdem kann man sagen, so Hierarchien sind einfach da, die sind einfach Fakt, sie existieren und es ist der Großteil von Organisationen,
wenn also gefühlt alle, die eigentlich so funktionieren, und die Modelle, wo man versucht, das anders zu machen, sind wahrscheinlich an wenigen Händen abzählbar.
Also ich möchte da vielleicht noch, ich habe das vorher schon erwähnt mit make, buy or network.
Und ich würde sagen, der Network-Ansatz und das ist auch ein Thema, das mich begleitet, seit ich in der Uni bin
oder meine Diplomarbeit war zum Thema OpenSource Software Entwicklung als Netzwerkorganisation.
Und da merkt man, es gibt halt auch Bereiche und es gibt Ansätze, die eigentlich, zumindest wenn nicht hierarchisch heterarchisch,
also quasi mit mehreren Zentren.
Also da gibt es nicht ein Zentrum, sondern es gibt mehrere so mächtige Teilorganisationen, die müssen sich abstimmen.
Da wird es dann eben verhandelt, ausverhandelt.
Auch das ganze internationale Recht funktioniert eigentlich so.
Wenn man so will, okay es gibt einen Hegemon der USA, aber ansonsten ist es ja auch so, dass da nicht primär eine Hierarchie ist.
Es gibt Macht und die ist nicht gleich verteilt, aber es ist nicht so, dass es die Hierarchie im engeren Sinne, nämlich einer klaren, wenn man so will,
Befehlskette, wie in der militärischen Hierarchie oder eben am Ende auf eine Spitze zulaufende Management, dass dann entscheidet.
Und was dann schon interessant ist, auch aus einer betriebswirtschaftlichen Perspektive, dass in manchen Kontexten
oder für manche Aufgaben Netzwerke, die bewusst eigentlich sich einer klar hierarchischen Struktur verweigern, Vorteile haben können.
Also zum Beispiel wenn es darum geht, offen für Innovationen für Neues zu sein.
Da ist oftmals so eine Netzwerkstruktur besser als eine enge Hierarchie, wo alles nach oben quasi abgesegnet werden muss,
sondern in einer Netzwerkstruktur können halt diese einzelnen Netzwerkknoten, wenn man so will, eigenständig Innovationsentscheidungen treffen,
müssen nicht alles quasi absegnen lassen.
Und der Klassiker in der Organisationsforschung, der bekannteste Fall, an dem das quasi verhandelt wurde, ist das Toyota Knowledge Sharing Network,
die quasi in den 80er/90er Jahren den US-Automobilherstellern so richtig das Fürchten gelehrt haben.
Und was die eben gemacht haben ist eben genau so ein Mittelding oder eben die sagen, wir wollen, dass unser Zuliefernetzwerk,
dass die eigenständig sind, wir wollen, dass die selbstständig ihre Schwerpunkte für Innovationen in den einzelnen Teilfeldern,
wo sie tätig sind, suchen und wir wollen die auch nicht nur gegeneinander ausspielen, sondern was wir darüber hinaus noch machen,
wir organisieren, dass die auch untereinander beginnen Wissen auszutauschen, obwohl die vielleicht sogar Wettbewerber sind.
Und damit das aber möglich ist, müssen wir Strukturen etablieren, dass die nicht Angst haben, dass wir sie morgen sofort ersetzen.
Das heißt, man geht längerfristige Austauschbeziehungen ein.
Man sagt quasi, wir machen zwar einen Markttest, aber eigentlich ist das eine kooperative Beziehung, in der wir uns befinden
und nicht nur cutthroat competition, also Halsabschneiderwettbewerb, wie das halt teilweise in USA ist.
General Motors ist immer das Gegenbeispiel, wo die halt immer neu ausschreiben.
Also quasi da gibt es fünf Jahre einen Zuliefervertrag, dann wird neu ausgeschrieben, alles auf null gestellt
und dann wird quasi wieder, wer das günstigste Angebot hat, kommt zum Zug.
Was bedeutet, dass die erstens sehr wenig Geld haben zu investieren, dass die natürlich auf ihrem Wissen extrem draufhocken,
weil wir geben da nichts wem anderen, weil wer weiß, das ist unser Konkurrent in der nächsten Ausschreiberunde.
Was bedeutet, dass in diesem ganzen Zuliefernetzwerk von General Motors Wissen viel schwerer quasi sich verbreitet
und damit es langsamer, nicht so innovativ ist.
Und das hat man bei Toyota eben viel besser hinbekommen, ich würde sagen, heute ist die Situation wieder ein bisschen anders.
Warum?
In den 90er/2000er Jahren haben sich dann diese großen Zulieferer herausgebildet.
In Österreich recht bekannt ist Magna, vielleicht kennt man die in Deutschland auch, also sind so große Automobilzulieferer,
die in Wirklichkeit ja sogar ganze Autos produzieren können.
Also Magna ist ja Auftragsfertiger für aber verschiedene Händler, also verschiedene Autohersteller.
Die stellen BMW Autos her, genauso wie Mercedes, irgendwelche Geländewagen.
Oder auch im Technologiebereich FoxCon etc.
Genau, die machen eigentlich für alle möglichen Handyhersteller fertigen die.
Selbst im Technologiebereich bei den Global Foundries, also bei den Computerchips ist das auch so,
da ist Intel der integrierte Hersteller, aber eigentlich der einzige, der das noch wirklich so hinkriegt
und alle anderen bestellen quasi bei den Auftragsfertigern.
Und das hat nochmal wieder eine andere Dynamik ausgelöst.
Weil hat, wenn ich Autos für verschiedene Hersteller herstelle als Zulieferer, dann natürlich verspreche ich denen das Wissen,
was es immer es gibt, das ist geheim, aber natürlich diffundiert das dann.
Und spätestens bei der nächsten Runde kann ich auch Dinge, die ich bei BMW gelernt habe, in der Fertigung von Mercedes einsetzen.
Und damit ist es so, dass Wissen auch wiederum verbreitet wird.
Also man merkt da schon auch, ich würde sagen, innovative wirtschaftliche Entwicklung hat immer auch ein bisschen damit zu tun,
dass eben Unternehmen nicht zu mächtig und nicht zu totale Kontrolle über ihr Wissen haben dürfen, weil Fortschritt schon auch dadurch entsteht,
dass eben Wissen Verbreitung findet in Wegen, die die Leute, die das gerne kontrollieren würden, gar nicht gern sehen.
Wir reden ja jetzt eigentlich über mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig, die zweifelsohne zusammenhängen, nicht?
Also auf der einen Seite die Frage, wie ist eine Organisation aufgestellt, welche Struktur gibt sie sich,
wie hierarchisch oder inhierarchisch ist sie und inwiefern tut eine Hierarchie innerhalb dieser Organisation auch gut?
Wo lagere ich dann auch vielleicht Teile aus und gehe auch sozusagen in ein Netzwerk über,
womit wir ja im Prinzip von dem gesamten Markt auch reden.
Das heißt, da ist dann sozusagen auch die Grenze der Organisation in gewisser Hinsicht an einer oder mehreren Stellen wieder offen.
Aber ich würde trotzdem gerne nochmal sozusagen erst mal so diese Situation innerhalb einer Organisation,
weil in dem Moment, wo man halt Chef ist oder Chefin und einfach in irgendeiner Form einen Laden zusammenhalten muss,
entsprechende rechtliche Strukturen auch existieren, die mehr oder weniger klar sagen, hier fängt dein Laden an, da ist er zu Ende,
stellen sich ja im Prinzip diese ganzen Fragen, die man im Markt hat, auch genauso gut innerhalb des Unternehmens.
Jetzt haben wir schon Automobilindustrie angesprochen, die ja, glaube ich, für vieles auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel ist,
weil sie einerseits so ein bisschen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Motor der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung war in den letzten 100 Jahren,
natürlich vor allem auch Österreich, Deutschland natürlich extrem stark, aber auch international
und was auch selber jetzt wiederum ein Sektor ist, der unter einem extremen Disruptionsdruck steht, weil wir eben jetzt diesen technologischen Umschwung haben.
Und das ist ja dann immer so der Moment, wo etablierte Systeme gerne auseinander fliegen,
wo einfach auf einmal andere technische oder energietechnische Rahmenbedingungen oder auch politische Rahmenbedingungen zusammenkommen,
da kommt ja jetzt gleich eine ganze Menge auf einmal, wir haben den Klimawandel, wir haben sozusagen so einen politischen Druck,
einen gesellschaftlichen Druck, der da ist, andere Antriebsformen zu machen,
aber es zeigt sich ja auch, dass eben zeitgleich auch technologisch auf einmal was anderes möglich ist.
Batterietechnologie evolviert, zeigt erste Ergebnisse, man sieht so, aha okay, Elektrofahrzeuge können nicht nur ähnliche Effizienzen erreichen,
sondern sind teilweise schon besser, können Dinge tun, die gar nicht möglich sind.
Auch in der Art und Weise, wie sich ein Konzern aufstellt, also es war ja zum Beispiel lange Zeit überhaupt nicht möglich,
in diesen Automobilmarkt reinzudrängen, wenn man eben nicht Knowhow über Verbrennungsmaschinen hatte,
was einfach 50-60 Jahre lang Erfahrung, wenn man die erst mal aggregiert hat, die holt man mal nicht so von heute auf morgen nach.
Aber dann hat man auf einmal so Elektromotor, das kann jeder irgendwie seit 150 Jahren bauen, funktioniert so
und dann kann man halt zu Magna gehen und sagen, baut uns mal hier irgendwie eine Shell drumherum
und dann geht man zu Bosch und sagt, ja hier bitte noch ein bisschen Steuertechnik,
dann schraubt man das irgendwie zusammen, macht eine andere Marke drauf und dann ist man im Prinzip auch schon dabei.
Da müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, den Elefanten im Raum auch gleich mal benennen, Tesla ist gerade dabei, hier wirklich den Faden neu aufzunehmen
und eine Disruption zu liefern, wo, glaube ich, derzeit alle ganz schön ins Schwitzen kommen.
Pünktlich wirklich zu unserer Sendung ging heute so ein Dokument herum, das Tesla Anti Handbook Handbook,
was so ein dreiseitiges Pamphlet ist, was geleakt wurde, wo einfach mal kurz gesagt wird, ja lieber Mitarbeiter, so läuft das hier bei uns.
Und man würde halt jetzt erwarten, ah okay, das ist jetzt also hier so das Regelwerk, aber tatsächlich kommt das Dokument daher und sagt so,
ja nein, hier gibt es keine Regeln.
Nicht, dass es hier keine Rahmenbedingungen geben würde, die gibt es sehr wohl und die benennen wir jetzt auch,
aber wir benennen jetzt keine Regeln, weil Regeln sind ja nur sozusagen der Low Bar.
Also wenn du gegen Regeln verstößt, dann kannst du halt gar nicht mehr im Unternehmen bleiben, das ist sozusagen so das Minimum was du erfüllen musst,
aber wir wollen ja eigentlich woanders hin.
Wir wollen hier einen anderen Umgang miteinander haben und für uns sind andere Sachen wichtig.
Und dann kommt halt ganz am Anfang Vertrauen, Kommunikation, das sind sozusagen die wichtigen Sachen
und in gewisser Hinsicht auch so eine Verpflichtung zu einer Offenheit, aber auch zum Ignorieren.
Ignorieren ist vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort, aber zu einem anderen Umgang mit Hierarchien.
Also es gibt hier eine Shelf-Struktur, aber es wird halt jedem Mitarbeiter explizit gesagt so, ja bitte, also deine primäre Aufgabe ist,
uns erfolgreich zu machen und wenn du der Meinung bist, du hast in irgendeinem Bereich eine Idee oder einen Hinweis, was dazu beitragen kann,
dass wir erfolgreich sind oder aufhören weniger erfolgreich zu sein, dann ist es quasi deine Verpflichtung das auch zu benennen,
und du darfst aber auch zu jedem hingehen und du darfst sogar Elon Musk eine Email schreiben, ohne irgendjemanden zu fragen.
Also sozusagen ignoriere dieses Gedankengebäude der Hierarchie in dem Moment, tu es einfach.
Was fällt dir dazu ein?
Also dazu fällt mir natürlich eine große Menge ein.
Ja.
Ich meine, ich finde, wenn man das liest, ich habe das vorher auch kurz überflogen, dann sind da teilweise aber trotzdem extrem harte Sanktionen angedroht.
Also zum Beispiel kommst du einmal nicht zur Arbeit, ohne dass du vorher anrufst, das reicht, dass wir dich raushauen, einmal reicht.
Also nicht zweite Chance, sondern es kann sein, dass du nicht zur Arbeit kommen kannst, aber wenn du dich nicht abmeldest, dann war es das.
So und das ist nur einmal so, aber es ist ein paarmal so, wo man merkt so…
Ist schon noch Amerika.
Ja, nein es ist nicht so, dass quasi … ja also setz dich über Dinge hinweg, aber wehe es funktioniert nicht.
Also für mich, ich musste mich da erinnern an die Geschichte, ich habe das auch schon mal versucht nachzurecherchieren,
es gibt da Diskussionen, mit Historikern habe ich da schon mal drüber gestritten.
Aber es gibt die Geschichte und die ist gut genug und sie hat zumindest ein Tatsachensubstrat des höchsten Ordens,
den das österreichische k.u.k. Militär vergeben hat.
Das war der Maria-Theresien-Orden.
Und die Geschichte, ich sage immer die Geschichte, ob die dann ganz genau so stimmt oder wie sie dann wirklich gelebt wurde, ist eine andere Frage,
aber die Geschichte ist, diesen Orden konntest du nur bekommen, wenn du in der Schlacht quasi sei es auch befehlswidrig durch großen Mut
quasi doch noch zu einem Erfolg beigetragen hast.
Also die Ironie in diesem Orden ist quasi, wenn du dich quasi dem Befehl widersetzt und scheiterst, wirst du standrechtlich erschossen,
weil das ist quasi klar.
Aber wenn es quasi zum Erfolg führt, kriegst du einen Maria-Theresien-Orden.
Und ein bisschen atmet dieses Dokument von Tesla diesen Geist.
Also man lädt die gesamte Verantwortung auf den Mitarbeiterin oder Mitarbeiter ab, also im Sinne von,
es geht darum, dass wir erfolgreich sind, wir sagen dir schon, wofür du verantwortlich bist, aber nimm es nicht zu genau,
wenn du irgendwas besser machen kannst, mache es besser.
Aber ich meine, okay wenn es irgendwie quasi nicht gut funktioniert und ein Problem ist, tschüss.
Es gibt Leute, die finden das sicher toll, weil die sagen, natürlich ist das so diese Managementaufgabe,
nämlich Arbeit nicht nur zu erledigen, sondern auch zu organisieren, nämlich zu schauen den Kontext im Sinn haben und so.
Das ist natürlich was, was so der Traum ist.
Die Mitarbeiterin, der Mitarbeiter die alle eigenmotiviert nach Verbesserung streben und so.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht für alle was.
Und das bedeutet Druck, das bedeutet zusätzlich zu den Aufgaben, die von dir erwartet werden, eben noch mehr zu tun,
ohne dass du irgendwie deshalb mehr Zeit dafür hast notwendigerweise.
Gleichzeitig kann das natürlich sehr motivierend sein.
Also ich will das jetzt nicht nur wegtrashen oder sagen, das ist nur schlecht oder das ist nur die neoliberale Vereinzelung,
obwohl das sicher ein paar Aspekte da schon hat, aber ich würde sagen, das kann für bestimmte Leute sehr attraktiv sein,
dann in so einem Kontext zu arbeiten und es kann aber auch manche Leute sehr belasten.
Also die einfach finden, ich muss schauen, ich brauche meine ganze Kraft, um meinen Job zu erledigen
und jetzt muss ich auch noch irgendwie da Innovationsbeauftragter sein und noch überlegen, wo wir alles ändern,
ich hätte eigentlich gerne einen Manager, der sagt, wie wir es ändern.
Naja gut, ich meine, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein sehr elitäres Ding.
Sicherlich kann nicht jedes Unternehmen so agieren, weil man sozusagen explizit auf die Leute aus ist, die halt hier auch am besten performen
und die viel Spaß daran haben, das auch zu tun oder das zumindest anzustreben.
Trotzdem was da ja ein bisschen mit drinsteckt ist eben dieses Abweichen von der traditionellen Berichtsordnung.
So dieses Prinzip des Weiterreichens in Hierarchien, wo ja dann klassischerweise Informationen auch immer auf jeder Ebene,
wenn sie weitergereicht werden, immer leicht modifiziert, angepasst, je nachdem wie es für die Protektion dieser Ebene passend ist,
dann verändert werden.
Und hier wird man ja nun explizit ermutigt, genau ein solches träges System gar nicht erst zu ermutigen.
Ja.
Jetzt kann ich zum ersten Mal so was bringen.
Also wenn im Management oder Betriebswirtschaft, aber Management ganz besonders, hat eh einen schlechten Ruf,
weil es die Idee gibt, Management Moden.
Also es wird immer wieder eine neue Sau durch das Dorf getrieben, am besten mit einem neuen schönen shiny …
Lean Management war … also die Toyota-Story, die ich vorher erzählt habe, das war Lean Management at its best
Lean Management.
und das war sozusagen Peak Lean Management war Toyota just in time.
Aber dann, was haben wir jetzt gerade, Agilität, also alle wollen gerade agil sein.
Dazwischen hatten wir mal schon, oder in den 70ern schon hatten wir mal selbststeuernde Teams
und wenn man Agilität und selbststeuernde Teams zusammen liest, dann muss man da die Unterschiede mit der Lupe suchen.
Aber es ist jetzt ganz agil und das geht nur wegen dem Internet jetzt.
Und ich würde sagen, diese Tesla-Geschichte, was die da machen,
Also man hat das da als eher zwei Pole des Organisieren gegenüber gestellt, aber als zwei Formen der Organisation.
Die Machine Bureaucracy, also die Maschinen-Bürokratie, die halt wirklich verschriftlichte Regeln,
alles muss genauso laufen wie es vorgegeben ist, das Management plant das und dann wird umgesetzt,
also das ist so der ganz klassische Bürokratieansatz.
Aber schon damals gab es auch die Option, dass das für manche Dinge sehr gut geeignet ist, nämlich gerade wenn es zum Beispiel um Skaleneinträge geht
und eigentlich man könnte sagen, für Automobilhersteller wäre das so der Klassiker.
Organische Organisation ist hingehen flache Hierarchien, Leute machen das was ansteht.
Also jedes StartUp funktioniert eigentlich teilweise so, da gibt es zwar auch Aufgaben, aber man macht eigentlich das was gerade zu tun ist.
Und aber ein bisschen gibt es so…
Und zwischen diese beiden Idealtypen, wenn man so will, gab es immer schon ganz viele Mischformen.
Man hat immer versucht, teilweise auch große Organisationen quasi so zu hybridisieren und da Bereiche zu machen,
wo eben das eher organisch funktioniert.
Also Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilungen funktionieren immer ein bisschen anders wie quasi die Produktionsabteilungen.
Und selbststeuernde Teams, die ich erwähnt habe, sind genau so ein Ansatz gewesen.
Man sagt, man verlagert die Verantwortung darüber, wie der Prozess im Detail abzulaufen hat, auf Ebene der Teams,
also wirklich sehr weit runter.
Und da gibt es auch teilweise Rotationen, also da gibt es nicht nur einen Teamleader, sondern die können auch noch sich abwechseln.
Und was Tesla da so ein bisschen macht, aber besser verkauft als andere, sind genau solche Ansätze.
Man versucht einerseits, Verantwortung auf untere Ebenen zu verlagern und das kombiniert halt trotzdem mit einer Ansage,
die halt auffordert ein bisschen auch so und das ist das Maria-Theresien-ordenhafte da so.
Eine latente Aufforderung zum Regelbruch im Sinne der Regel.
Also die Regel wurde aufgestellt, um effizient zu produzieren, wenn du aber drauf kommst, das ist nicht effizient mit dieser Regel
und du sie deshalb brichst, dann ist es ja quasi im Sinne der Regel dieser Regelbruch.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn man es jetzt mal word by word nimmt sagen sie ja explizit, Regeln in dem Sinne haben wir nicht so.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen tongue and cheek, weil klar leiten sich hier zumindest bestimmte Rahmenbedingungen ab.
Andererseits muss man sagen, bei Tesla habe ich jetzt persönlich nicht so den Eindruck, aber es gibt ja noch das zweite Unternehmen von Elon Musk,
bei dem man davon ausgehen kann, dass es halt im Wesentlichen genauso funktioniert, Space X genau.
Die es ja geschafft haben, innerhalb von zehn Jahren von so quasi, wir gucken mal, ob wir eine Rakete gebaut bekommen, zu,
wir sind jetzt das führende Raumfahrttransportunternehmen, gebracht haben.
Und eine der Wege, das zu schaffen, ist halt so, wir akzeptieren halt auch Failure.
Also wir sind auch sozusagen bereit, Wege mal zu gehen und wenn die nichts werden ist das an sich nicht schlecht,
sondern auch daraus kann man was lernen.
Und ich denke, das ist etwas, was, ich weiß nicht, ob das neu ist, aber nicht unbedingt verbreitet ist.
Also Fail ist etwas, was auch Mitarbeitern Angst macht in Organisationen, was gerne auch mal bestraft wird.
Wir hatten das gerade so hier, deine Abteilung performt nicht und ja, da kam ja nichts bei raus, was Gewinn abgeworfen hat
oder das hat eben besonders viel gekostet, aber dass man eben auch aus einer Niederlage quasi etwas gewinnen kann,
nämlich festzustellen, ja okay so geht es nicht, heißt ja auch, man kann den Weg eben ausschließen
und gewinnt ja dann sozusagen für den potenziell richtigen Weg wieder neue Erkenntnisse.
Und das scheint mir hier dann doch wiederum auch mit eingegossen zu sein.
Solange du, bei Tesla gilt das ja noch mehr wie bei SpaceX, solange du genug Leute hast, die quasi weiterhin Geld nachschießen,
kannst du natürlich solche Fehler dir leisten.
Das ist ja die Frage, kannst du dir das leisten?
Also ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das irgendwie ein falscher Ansatz ist.
Aber einen Satz möchte ich noch sagen zu dem, die sagen ja, wir haben keine Regeln.
Und da möchte ich schon nochmal einhaken.
Als Organisationsforscher interessieren mich immer formale und informale Regeln.
Und es mag schon sein, dass sie keine formalen Regeln haben, aber umso wichtiger werden dann informale Regeln,
und die lerne ich nur, indem ich dann vor Ort bin und gegen die kann ich genauso verstoßen, die können teilweise noch schwerer zu ändern sein.
Also ich glaube, das muss man sich halt schon ganz klar vor Augen halten.
Und dieser Glaube, wenn nur diese störenden formalen Regeln weg wären, dann wären wir frei, dann könnten wir tun was wir wollen
und dann werden wir eigentlich wirklich viel effizienter, die Bürokratie hält uns nur zurück.
Und ein bisschen atmet dieses Tesla-Dokument auch diesen Geist einer Bürokratiekritik.
Und die ist ja nicht grundsätzlich völlig falsch.
Natürlich hat eine Bürokratie eine Tendenz zur Verstetigung, das ist ihre Aufgabe, die soll Dinge vorhersehbar machen lassen.
Also dass eine bürokratische Struktur vorhersehbar stabil ist, das ist quasi, it’s not a bug, it’s a feature.
Aber natürlich, wenn dann die Umwelt sich dynamisch ändert, wenn es radikale Umbrüche gibt, da sind wir wieder bei Fridays for Future.
Ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, wie lange die deutschen Automobilhersteller immer noch geglaubt haben,
das wird noch hundert Jahre dauern mit den Elektroautos und auf einmal fahren ihnen die Teslas um die Ohren,
dann merkt man, dass das dann manchmal, was gestern noch die Stärke war, nämlich eine gut geölte Maschinerie,
kann morgen bereits die Pfadabhängigkeit sein, aus der du raus willst.
Und vor diesem Dilemma steht man halt oft.
Und was jetzt so Tesla und SpaceX betrifft würde ich schon sagen, dass die manche Dinge auf jeden Fall richtig machen,
auch eine teilweise brutale Art, mit sehr viel Risiko.
Umgekehrt zum Beispiel gibt es Kritik, die ich so überhaupt nicht teile, wenn dann immer Leute zu Tesla schreiben,
ja die haben ja noch nie Gewinn gemacht, was soll das?
Und ich sage, das ist wirklich eine komische Denke.
Mittlerweile haben sie das auch getan.
Ich weiß, sie haben mittlerweile ein paar Quartale hintereinander schwarze Zahlen, aber das ist lächerlich verglichen mit dem Börsenwert, den die haben.
Klar.
Aber ich würde auch sagen, das ist natürlich, wenn du sagst, ich will quasi den Markt komplett umkrempeln, dann ist das natürlich ein Investment.
Und wenn ich dann den Markt sichere und wenn ich erkenne, wie Tesla das macht, dass es dann vielleicht auf einmal so was wie Netzwerkeffekte im Automobilmarkt gibt,
die zum Beispiel eben je mehr Autos ich auf der Straße habe, desto besser werden die Daten, die ich sammeln kann,
desto besser wird mein Autopilot, desto schneller bin ich dann beim selbstfahrenden Auto.
Und wenn ich der First Mover bin, der das erste und das größte Netzwerk auf den Straßen hat, dann können die anderen vielleicht gar nicht mehr mithalten.
Das ist ja so wie bei Google, wo quasi selbst Microsoft nachher mit unendlichem Geld keine Chance hatte,
Google wirklich im Suchmaschinenranking zu bedrohen, warum?
Weil Google die Nutzungsdaten hatte, die wiederum in die Suchergebnisse einfließen.
Und die kann ich nicht reproduzieren.
Das heißt, die einzige Chance, dass Google irgendwie Konkurrenz im Suchmaschinenmarkt bekommt, ist, dass man sie zwingt,
diese Daten quasi mit Mitbewerbern zu teilen, weil das ist nicht der Algorithmus die große Stärke, sondern die Daten sind die große Stärke
und die Nutzungsdaten eben, die Suchanfragen, die ständig gestellt werden.
Und solche Netzwerkeffekte gibt es eben auch bei zunehmend datafizierten Autos.
Und da ist es sozusagen so, die ersten zehn Jahre zahle ich da rein, dafür habe ich dann 30 Jahre, wo ich den Markt dominiere.
Das ist halt die Wette, die Investoren bei Tesla eingehen.
Und das ist nicht, weil die wollen nicht jetzt kurzfristig irgendwie ein bisschen eine Dividende.
Ja ist auch sehr interessant, also ich will jetzt nicht nur über Tesla reden, aber man kann da schon einiges dran festmachen.
Weil du ja auch vorhin sagtest, ja okay, wir haben jetzt hier auch sozusagen unser Netzwerk, was wir quasi auch zum Teil machen,
auch das ist ja in der Automobilindustrie extrem stark, also so was wie VW macht halt die Motoren, kloppt irgendwie sein VW-Logo drauf,
viele andere Unternehmen sind Zulieferer.
Die ganze Zulieferkette ist auch hochgradig voneinander abhängig.
Man tendiert aber dann auch sozusagen dazu, die Systeme in der Logik dieses etablieren Netzwerks zu denken.
Das heißt, wenn so ein Gerät gebaut wird, hat man halt irgendwie zahlreiche Steuerkomponenten von vielen vielen Herstellern,
wenn man sich da so mit Computersecurity-Leuten unterhält, die haben dann gleich die Hände auf dem Kopf und sagen so,
ja alles ganz furchtbar, fällt bald auseinander, weil man da eben auch nicht schnell mal was ändern kann.
Und das ist ja zum Beispiel bei Tesla auch so, dass die sozusagen all diese Dinge nicht drin haben.
Die haben da einfach so einen kleinen Supercomputer in ihrem Computer und machen quasi ganze Steuerungen neu,
denken das alles komplett neu, ownen das auch alles selber, haben diese Netzwerkabhängigkeiten,
also an der Stelle eben diese für sie potenziell ja schwierigen Netzwerkabhängigkeiten nicht mehr drin und können dadurch schneller voranmarschieren.
Ganz ganz genau, das ist, würde ich sagen, wenn man auch einer der größten betriebswirtschaftlich Organisationsforschungserkenntnisse der jüngeren Vergangenheit,
sage ich jetzt, so nach dem Ende der 90er Jahre, dann ist das der Bestseller, er ist glaube ich kürzlich verstorben, von Clayton Christonson, „The Innovators Dilemma“, also das Innovationsdilemma.
Der quasi eigentlich diese Begriffe Disruption so richtig geprägt hat.
Wo er immer unterscheidet zum Beispiel zwischen disruptiver und radikaler Innovation.
Es gibt Dinge, die technisch radikal neu sind, aber die Geschäftsmodelle nicht ändern und deshalb eigentlich Marktführer überhaupt nicht unter Druck setzen.
Und dann gibt es dinge, die ändern technisch nicht viel, aber die können trotzdem einen Markt komplett umkrempeln.
Das Buch kann ich wirklich einfach nur empfehlen zu lesen, auch für Leute, die überhaupt kein Interesse, keinen BWL-Hintergrund haben.
Das ist im Prinzip die Definition von der Disruption oder?
Ja, genau. Aber der zeigt das an schönen Beispielen, einerseits Festplattenindustrie, anderes Beispiel Bagger.
Also er sagt, eine Industrie, die extrem schnell Marktführerwechsel hatte, das ist die Festplattenindustrie.
Er sagt, das ist so, die Biologen machen Experimente mit Fruchtfliegen, weil die einen Tag nur leben und da kann man ganz viele Zyklen haben.
Und er sagt, ein Innovationsforscher sollte sich für die Festplattenindustrie interessieren, weil da die Marktführer mit jeder neuen Größe der Festplatte,
obwohl das sind alles nur Magnetplatten, das war noch lange vor Solid State Disc, die wir jetzt in den Laptops haben.
Aber jede neue Größe hat einen neuen Marktführer gebracht.
Also er beginnt da mit den Main Frames, mit den riesigen tonnenmäßigen Festplatten
und dann kam die nächstkleinere für die Micro-Computer.
Dann kam der PC, dann kam Laptop, dann kam Handy.
Und das Spannende war immer, die Marktführer im dominanten Markt, wo das meiste Geld verdient wurde, die waren super gut,
die Bedürfnisse der damals dominanten Märkte zu bedienen.
Also die, die quasi die großen Main Frame-Festplatten gebaut haben, die Main Frame-Hersteller haben die geliebt,
und was wollten die, weniger Kosten pro Megabyte.
Das war das Entscheidende, Größe ist egal, weil die stellen die sowieso irgendwo in die Halle.
Dann kamen aber die Micro-Computer oder die PCs und auf einmal waren die Kosten pro Megabyte nicht so wichtig wie die Größe.
Und die haben am Anfang gesagt, das ist ja egal, das lassen wir irgendwelchen, diese Nischenmärkte lassen wir irgendwelchen anderen.
Der Punkt ist, die Nischenmärkte sind bald erstens so stark gewachsen, dass sie größer waren als der Ursprungsmarkt
und die Technologie ist so fortgeschritten, dass die kleineren Festplatten auf einmal auch die Jobs der größeren besser
und zu günstigeren Preisen erledigen konnten und am Ende waren die out of Business.
Und das ist dann nicht einmal passiert, sondern x-mal.
Und der Christensen zeichnet das so schön nach.
Diese Manager waren ja keine Idioten, im Gegenteil, die waren super, die Firmen waren mega erfolgreich.
Die haben wirklich das gemacht, was ihre Kunden wollten.
Aber das Problem ist, wenn die quasi die anderen Dinge gemacht hätten, wäre die Gefahr gewesen,
dass sie ihre Kernmärkte kannibalisieren.
Das wollte man nicht.
Und das heißt, die haben eigentlich alles richtig gemacht und sind dann trotzdem gescheitert.
Und das ist das, was ihn so umgetrieben hat.
Und ich würde sagen, damit kommen wir jetzt zum Tesla zurück.
Das sind die schnelleren Pferde, die gerne als Zitat dem Ford zugeschrieben werden,
aber die irgendwo so ein bisschen auch die Wahrheit wiedergeben.
Genau.
Also ja, hätte man mich gefragt,…
Was wollen die Leute?
…was wollen die Leute, schnellere Pferde, aber ich habe ihnen halt ein Auto gegeben.
Und klar, man sieht es ja auch bei Apple, irgendwie so mit dem iPhone hat man auch quasi ein Angebot gemacht,
nach dem keiner gefragt hat.
Genau und da kommen wir aber zurück zu Pfadabhängigkeiten und zu Tesla.
Weil was du genau sagst ist, was der große Vorteil von Tesla war, ist, dass die die Idee von Tesla und das Auto auf die grüne Wiese gestellt haben.
Die hatten nicht den ganzen Legacy-Kram, mit dem die deutschen Automobilhersteller kämpfen.
Die müssen nämlich ihr Standardprogramm weiterfahren, das bedienen,
das hat sie bisher auch ausgelastet.
Es war nicht so, dass denen langweilig war und jetzt sollen sie parallel dazu sozusagen ein zweites Automobilkonzept auf den Boden bringen.
Und das Problem ist, diese Routinen, die da eingespielt sind und das sind verschränkte, verschachtelte Cluster von Routinen,
wenn ich da eine ändere, das funktioniert nicht so leicht.
Ich gebe dir ein anderes Beispiel, das ein Kollege von mir in seiner Doktorarbeit angeschaut hat,
wo es auch einen kompletten Marktführerwechsel gegeben hat, war im Filmentwicklungsbereich.
Und witzigerweise gibt es da ein deutsches Erfolgsbeispiel mal.
Also im Zuge der digitalen Revolution im Film- und Fotografiebereich sind die klassischen Marktführer,
Kodak und Fuji verschwinden, die gingen Konkurs oder sind bedeutungslos heute,
wo man sagen kann, eigentlich komisch.
Also die hatten die Technik am Schirm.
Filme entwickeln ist natürlich was anderes wie quasi irgendwelche digitalen Fotos zu entwickeln,
aber man braucht auch die Logistik, man muss im Markt präsent sein, man muss die einsammeln und ausdrucken und wieder verschicken oder so.
Und die haben es alle nicht geschafft, warum?
Weil die eben geglaubt haben, wir haben unsere etablieren Routinen für analoge Fotografie und da docken wir das halt irgendwie da dran.
Wer überlebt hat war, witzigerweise kannte man die Marke vorher gar nicht, jetzt kennt man sie,
Cewe Fotobücher sagen dir vielleicht was?
Ja.
Cewe war früher so ein White Label Entwickler.
Das heißt, die haben für andere Markenhersteller haben die Fotos entwickelt.
Und wie dann die digitale Transformation da schon irgendwie langsam an die Tür geklopft hat,
haben die gesagt, naja eigentlich müssten wir da was tun, aber irgendwie puh.
Und haben das ausgelagert, komplett auf die grüne Wiese quasi, und haben gesagt, ihr macht jetzt den Digitalkrempel.
Wirklich eigenes Gebäude, eigenes Management, ihr kümmert euch dadrum.
Ist halt eine Tochter von uns, aber ihr macht mal.
Und die haben einfach das aufgebaut und am Ende war es so, wie quasi die analoge Fotografie tot war,
sind die Überreste von dem dann aufgegangen in der neuen digital Division,
die dann mit Fotobüchern, mit Fotoapparaten in Drogenmärkten und so weiter eigentlich das komplett neu aufgezogen hatten,
mit einer komplett neuen Routinenlogik, und deshalb haben die überlebt.
Und alle, die geglaubt haben, wir kriegen das schon irgendwie hin, die haben es nicht überlebt.
Also dieses, Dinge mal auf die grüne Wiese zu stellen, und wenn ich jetzt noch einen Sprung machen darf,
dass das eben wirklich auch was universelles ist, was nicht nur im Business-Bereich,
sondern auch in anderen Bereichen oftmals … oftmals ist es einfach besser, Dinge komplett neu zu machen,
und nicht quasi zu glauben, das irgendwie zu retten, das ist der Bereich, wo wir am Anfang kurz besprochen haben,
in dem ich auch bin, im Fernsehrat.
Es gibt nämlich, das glauben die wenigsten, es gibt ein großes Erfolgsbeispiel auch für Digitalisierung im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk,
was genau dieser Logik folgt.
Und zwar wissen wir alle, die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen tun sich im Internet nicht so leicht.
Da sind sie nicht nur selber dran schuld, …
… sondern das ist auch teilweise einfach die Staats…
… die gesetzliche Regel.
… die gesetzliche Regel des Staatsvertrags sagt halt einfach, ihr dürft da nur sehr eingeschränkt agieren.
Genau.
Hat sich ein bisschen gestern geändert …
Seit 01. Mai 2019 dürfen sie auch Angebote nur für das Internet entwickeln.
Vorher durften sie nur Dinge machen, die nur so Anhängselprodukte waren von dem, was sie ausgesendet haben.
Also nicht nur deren Schuld.
Aber trotzdem muss man natürlich sagen, die Mediatheken sehr geringe Reichweite unter den jungen Leuten.
Das lineare Programm stark veraltet.
Und gleichzeitig wo sind die jungen Zielgruppen, die schlecht erreicht werden?
Die tummeln sich auf den kommerziellen Plattformen, Facebook, YouTube, Instagram, TikTok, you name them.
Und vor diese Frage gestellt hat man 2013/14/15 so begonnen zu diskutieren über ein Jugendangebot der Öffentlich-Rechtlichen.
Weil man gesagt hat, okay die alten Sender erreichen die Jungen schwer, da brauchen wir einen Jugendsender, war die Idee.
So, glücklicherweise, Sender sind teuer, also Sendeinfrastruktur, Einspeisevergütungen, Sender kosten sehr viel Geld.
Und in dem Moment hat man gesagt, naja das ist so viel Geld, brauchen wir überhaupt einen Sender,
können wir das nicht einsparen?
Und das war ein Glücksfall, man hat dann quasi ein Jugendangebot gegründet und hat gesagt,
die Jungen sind sowieso im Internet, also lassen wir den Sender weg.
Man hat zwei Spartensender eingestellt, einen von ZDF und einen von der ARD und das Geld genommen von diesen zwei Spartensendern
und damit das Jugendangebot FUNK gegründet, das gibt es jetzt seit zweieinhalb-drei Jahren
und für alle die, die das nicht kennen, weil dann sind sie wahrscheinlich nicht Zielgruppe,
also Zielgruppe dieses Senders ist 15-25/29 und die produzieren nur für digitale Plattformöffentlichkeit.
Das heißt, in Wirklichkeit ist das ein Multichannel-Network auf YouTube, aber sie probieren alle Plattformen aus.
Haben das 60:90 Format, das zahlt auch ein auf das was du gesagt hast, die haben seit sie gestartet sind,
und zweieinhalb muss man sich vorstellen, haben die über hundert Formate ausprobiert,
aber aktiv sind nur noch 60.
Also man merkt schon auch, experimentell, scheitern lassen, scheitern nicht nur als Problem sehen,
sondern scheitern als Teil der Lösung.
Und eben ganz anders als im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, wo, wenn irgendeine Sendung mal eingestellt wird,
nach 35 Jahren dann gleich noch die Petition kommt, aber bitte jetzt nicht.
Und das ist halt dort schon anders.
Ich meine, auch da gibt es teilweise böse Artikel, wenn dann was eingestellt wird, aber das ist auch wieder weg,
weil dann kommen schon wieder drei neue Formate.
Und wenn man sich die Zahlen anschaut, die haben jetzt in zwei Jahren über eine Milliarde Views,
sind in über 70% der Zielgruppe kennen entweder Funk oder ein Funk-Format und das aber im Wettbewerbsumfeld YouTube.
Also es ist nicht so, dass da Leute gedacht haben, na endlich kommen die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen.
Also es ist ja nicht so als hätte man darauf gewartet.
Und da muss man sagen, und um das nochmal deutlich zu machen, warum schaffen die das?
Also die zwei, die das vor allem verantworten sind der Flo Hager und die Sophie Burkhardt, das sind so die Leiterinnen.
Und ich war da einmal auch zu Besuch.
Die sitzen in Mainz, in Mainz sitzt ja auch das ZDF mit dem Lerchenberg und der SWR.
Aber sie sind bewusst weder im Lerchenberg noch beim SWR, sondern die haben sich eingemietet in den Bonifatiustürmen in Mainz.
Also damals schlechteste Gegend, Bahnhofsviertel, halbleer diese Türmen.
Zahlen 10 Euro den Quadratmeter, obwohl beste Lage direkt neben dem Bahnhof.
Inzwischen sind die eh wieder voll, und haben halt wirklich so, wenn man da raufgeht, die sind da ganz oben,
bestes Startup-Ambiente.
Also wirklich so, da steht der Kicker, also alles was man aus Startup-Klischees sich nur vorstellen kann und mehr.
Aber dazu zählt zum Beispiel Hotdesk, keiner hat ein Büro, mit keiner meine ich, Sophie Burkhard und Flo Hager haben kein Büro.
Man stelle sich vor, irgendeiner von den Intendanten hätte kein Büro ohne Vorzimmer und Besprechungsraum, undenkbar.
Aber das ist genau das, was ich damit meine, das ist eine Art von Führung, ich kann hundertmal sagen,
wir haben flache Hierarchien, aber ich brauche es gar nicht sagen, wenn ich kein Büro haben, weil dann weiß es jeder.
Also das ist einfach dann klar.
Und dann kommuniziert das viel mehr eine Offenheit und eine, wir machen das hier ganz anders als am Lerchenberg,
also ich kann hundertmal sagen, wir machen es anders, wenn ich so agiere, wenn ich mein Büro schon so baue,
wenn ich nur offene Großraumbüros habe und den Leuten da wirklich sage, wir sind da wirklich anders aufgestellt,
wir machen das anders, wir haben eine andere Zielgruppe, das haben die einfach hinbekommen.
Und trotzdem das wäre nie gelungen, hätte man da jetzt eine Abteilung im ZDF dafür aufgemacht.
Ich sage ein Gegenbeispiel.
Im ZDF hat man versucht, die junge Zielgruppe im Nachrichtenbereich zu erreichen und vielleicht kennen das einige,
läuft gerade aus, heute plus gegründet.
Heute plus war so die Idee, die 24-Uhr-Nachrichten die geben wir so quasi dem Internet.
Und die haben die Aufgabe als junge Nachrichtenredaktion auch das Internet, und das ist der Punkt, mitzubespielen.
Wenn du aber quasi jeden Tag eine Nachrichtensendung im Hauptprogramm linear hast, mit über einer Million Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern,
dann schlägt die mal alles andere.
Das heißt, wenn die nicht steht und gut ist, dann ist alles andere egal.
Das heißt, du musst das erst mal hinkriegen und nur wenn dann noch Zeit bleibt,
kannst du noch was fürs Netz machen.
Aber genau das ist das Problem, du musst dich auf das Netz konzentrieren können,
weil da draußen gibt es ganz viele Redaktionen, Angebote und so weiter, die konzentrieren sich nur auf’s Netz.
Und das sind andere Logiken, das folgt ganz anderen Prinzipien.
Und das hat aber bei heute plus in der Hybridlogik so nie funktioniert.
Und Funk hat funktioniert, weil man es wie bei Tesla auf die grüne Wiese gestellt hat und gesagt hat, ihr könnt bei null anfangen,
ihr stellt euch alle Leute neu ein, ihr kriegt ein neues Büro, ich müsst auch, schon alleine die Büros sind dann teilweise das Problem.
Wenn du in diesem alten Lerchenberg Verwaltungshochhaus bist, dann wird es schwierig,
quasi da irgendwie agil zu sein.
Das heißt, der öffentliche Rundfunk ist noch zu retten?
Also das Leben hat mich vor zu viel Optimismus geheilt.
Aber ich meine, mit ist noch zu retten, wenn du meinst …
Ich bin ja Forscher, ich bin Theoretiker, also theoretisch ja, die Frage ist praktisch.
Ich würde so sagen, Funk macht mir schon Mut und mir macht auch Mut,
dass die Rundfunkgesetzgebung eben letztes Jahr ernsthaft den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen mehr Spielräume eröffnet hat.
Ab jetzt kann man sie wirklich auch bald zur Verantwortung ziehen, wenn sie quasi dann nicht neue Angebote jetzt noch schaffen,
die im Digitalen auch besser funktionieren.
Man muss natürlich sagen, eigentlich haben sie ja mit der Beitragsfinanzierung ja eh, also sind sie ja nicht so akut bedroht wie Regionalzeitungen.
Also insofern, ich würde sagen, die größte Bedrohung für den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk droht aus der Politik eigentlich.
Weil wenn man sich anschaut, Boris Johnson, der die BBC gerade irgendwie von Gebührenfinanzierung auf Steuerfinanzierung gesund oder kaputtschrumpfen will.
Wenn man in Österreich, wo die Freiheitlichen, die jetzt ja nicht mehr in der Regierung sind,
aber die hatten die letzten zwei Jahre auch im Regierungsprogramm stehen, Umstellung auf Steuerfinanzierung und Kürzung.
In der Schweiz gab es da auch eine Abstimmung darüber.
In der Schweiz gab es die Abstimmung.
Also man merkt schon, also die Legitimation der Öffentlich-Rechtlichen steht mehr infrage als das früher so war.
Und da sind die neuen digitalen Öffentlichkeiten einerseits ein Grund dafür,
aber auch etwas, was das vielleicht noch verstärkt.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, das zu beklagen hilft nicht.
Ich glaube, das Entscheidende ist, dass man zeigt, dass man auch im digitalen Zeitalter relevant ist und Geld genug dafür hätte man.
Und jetzt, würde ich sagen, liegt der Ball schon im Feld der Öffentlich-Rechtlichen,
mit diesen neuen rechtlichen Möglichkeiten, denen auch gerecht zu werden.
Ich meine, ich sage das wirklich in voller Kenntnis als alter Pfadabhängigkeitsforscher wie schwer das ist.
Also Dinge umzuschichten aus etablierten linearen Programmen.
Und die Herausforderung, vor der die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen stehen, die ist eben nicht gering.
Weil eigentlich ist, was man ZDF und ARD sagt, also alles was ihr bisher gemacht habt, macht ihr weiter, alles.
Also quasi ihr bespielt dieses Vollprogramm linear, alles, was wir da haben, das muss weiterlaufen wie bisher,
wehe es kommt ein Fehler, weil dann gleich Lügenpresse, aber außerdem investiert ihr jetzt quasi in die neuen digitalen Formate,
ihr macht alles neu, macht alle neuen Dinge für’s Netz.
Übrigens mehr Geld gibt es quasi nicht.
Und wir haben ja auch noch ein paar gesetzliche Auflagen, was ihr alles nicht tun dürft.
Das und wehe ihr macht einen Text da rein, weil das ist ja presseähnlich.
Also das ist für mich das … ja, also das ist das absurdeste, in einer komplett multimedialen digitalen Öffentlichkeit zu sagen,
die dürfen keine Texte da reinstellen, weil das sind presseähnliche.
Das Wort presseähnlich ist sowieso schon so irre.
Und ich finde das deshalb so schlimm, weil ich finde, was ist ein digitales Nachrichtenangebot?
Das ist natürlich crossmedial und man macht das beste for the job und manchmal ist ein Text einfach das beste.
Und denen jetzt zu sagen, ihr dürft keine Texte schreiben, weil das sieht dann zu ähnlich aus wie bei Bild.de,
die jetzt sich quasi eh um eine Rundfunklizenz bewerben müssen, weil sie so viel Video haben.
Das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Also die werden zum Fernsehsender und die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen dürfen keine Texte schreiben,
das ist völlig anachronistisch.
Aber gut, man merkt, das regt mich auf.
Aber ich habe da auch drüber …
Na gut, aber auf jeden Fall das Thema Innovation/Disruption ist auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Aspekt,
wenn man sich sozusagen das Funktionieren von Organisationen anschaut
und dann eben auch einen potenziellen Lebenskampf an der Stelle führt.
Gerade das öffentlich-rechtliche Modell ist natürlich jetzt so eine sehr mitteleuropäische Geschichte.
Das findet sich ja so ohne weiteres nicht überall.
Man sieht ja in anderen Ländern, wo es so ein Modell nicht gibt, dass es da medial auch gleich noch sehr viel schwieriger wird.
Großbritannien hat zwar auch beides und das steht halt jetzt auch unter Feuer,
wird sich zeigen, aber an der Stelle muss eben eine Organisation auch eine gewisse Resilienz dann entwickeln zu sagen,
okay wir sind zwar davon überzeugt, dass wir wichtig sind, aber jetzt müssen wir eben auch Wege finden,
wie das auch allen anderen klar wird, da ist dann vielleicht der Zug auch noch nicht komplett abgefahren.
Ja, so würde ich sagen.
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich und wir sind ja schon zwei-dreimal schon tief reingerutscht in diesen Pfad,
aber auch nochmal konkret auf die Auswirkungen durch moderne Technologie und natürlich ganz konkret auch durch das Internet kommen.
Und da sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal spezifisch auch auf dein Forschungsfeld ansprechen.
Klang ja schon an, OpenSource hat eine große Rolle gespielt und die Wikipedia-Bewegung auch.
Gehen wir das doch jetzt mal ein bisschen zielgerichteter an.
Also OpenSource-Phänomen und das Wikipedia-Phänomen, so würde ich das jetzt mal nennen,
sind ja eigentlich totale Erfolgsgeschichten, kann man eigentlich nicht anders sagen.
OpenSource hat einfach eine extreme sehr breitbandige technologische Entwicklung vorangetrieben,
die heutzutage auch die Grundlage eigentlich allen digitalen Wirtschaftens ist.
Das kann niemand bestreiten.
Gibt kaum einen Server, oder es gibt wahrscheinlich überhaupt kein System auf diesem Planeten mehr,
was nicht in irgendeiner Form davon profitiert.
Das heißt nicht, dass es immer einfach ist oder die beste Lösung, aber das ist auf jeden Fall mal Fakt.
Und hier haben sich Organisationsformen herausgebildet, die extrem weit weg sind von dem, was wir jetzt bisher besprochen haben.
Wikipedia hat sich das dann sozusagen angeschaut und mit dieser großartigen Idee einer Enzyklopädie,
die in gewisser Hinsicht so eine Idee war, die naja einerseits großartig ist, andererseits auch ein bisschen auf dem Tisch lag,
auch schon von Douglas Adams in seinem Werk „Per Anhalter durch die Galaxis“ in gewisser Hinsicht vorhergesagt wurde
und dann war das auch wieder so eine self fulfilling prophecy.
Was siehst du in diesen beiden Bewegungen an Neuem und an Verheißungsvollem und an auch Schwierigem natürlich?
Diese Struktur, also diese Tyrannei der Strukturlosigkeit, ich glaube, der Begriff fiel schon mal,
was hast du da vorgefunden, wie hast du dir das angeschaut?
Also zunächst fand ich eben das Spannende an OpenSource diese Idee, dass man quasi Wissen auf eine Art und Weise,
dass man die digitalen Möglichkeiten, Wissen zu verbreiten, auf eine Art und Weise nutzt,
so dass möglichst viele andere Menschen quasi den Faden aufnehmen und weiter innovativ kreativ tätig sein zu können.
Also wenn wir über Internet reden, ist ja oft der Eindruck, alles ganz neu oder wird oft so getan, als wäre das alles ganz neu,
Aber umso mehr macht es mir dann auch immer Spaß, so das irgendwie versuchen, zumindest so in einen historischen Kontext zu stellen.
Da würde ich sagen, ja, in der Vergangenheit gab es schon mal solche Wissensrevolutionen.
Und ich meine, der Buchdruck mit beweglichen Lettern, der wird dann eh am öftesten als quasi letzte große Informationsrevolution …
Ich würde ja das Telefon noch mit reinbringen wollen.
Ja, aber ich finde, für die Dissemination, also Radio vielleicht, so dieses Ganze, ja, kann man drüber diskutieren.
Ich finde, aber man merkt, was damals halt auch kam, war eine unfassbare Verbreitung von Wissen
und auf einmal konnten viel mehr Menschen kreativ innovativ auf Basis des Wissensbestandes weiterarbeiten.
Also ich glaube, was ja völlig unterschätzt wird, es gibt da so ein Doppelband, ich habe es nicht zur Gänze gelesen,
weil es so dick ist, über die Geschichte des Urheberrechts von Eckhard Höffner,
wo der halt versucht nachzuzeichnen, dass in Deutschland, damals im zersplitterten Deutschland vor der Vereinigung,
vor Bismarck, wenn man so will, dass es da zum Beispiel Raubdrucke von eher so Handbüchern,
so wie man Dinge erledigen kann, sehr weit verbreitet waren.
Und dass das mit einen Grundstock dafür gelegt hat, dass Deutschland dann recht schnell aufgeholt hat,
was industrielle Entwicklung betrifft.
Zweites Beispiel Amerika, USA waren geistige Eigentumsrechte, wie sie dann in Europa schon etabliert waren,
immer noch eigentlich relativ wenig ausgeprägt, wurden nicht stark durchgesetzt.
Also wenn man so will, mitgeholfen beim wirtschaftlichen Aufstieg der USA hat auch sehr viel Piraterie.
Also diese ganze Idee, dass ein Regime, mit dem wir unser Wissen regulieren, dass das eigentlich vielleicht vorher,
schon vor dem Internet, vielleicht zu restriktiv war.
Dass aber dann so ein Beispiel wie OpenSource-Software auch zeigt, welche Potenziale ein anderer Zugang zur Regulierung von Wissen
und das ist genau das, was ja die große Innovation von OpenSource-Software war, war ja eigentlich,
wenn man Richard Stallman mit freier Software in den 80ern sieht, noch vor dem Internet.
Und die große Innovation war dann eigentlich eine rechtliche Idee.
Nämlich zu sagen, diesen alle Rechte vorbehalten des klassischen Urheberrechts, die mal bedeuten.
wenn jemand anderer was nutzen will von mir, dann muss er das mit mir abklären, egal was es ist und egal auf welche Art und Weise.
Und dass Richard Stallman mit seiner Idee der freien Software-Lizenz das irgendwie auf den Kopf gestellt hat
und gesagt hat, nein, ich will, dass ganz viele Dinge erstens ohne Rechteklärung einfach möglich sind,
ohne dass man das mit mir im Einzelfall abstimmen muss.
Und ich nutze das Recht eher dafür, dass diese Freiheit, Dinge weiter zu nutzen, zu verändern, innovativ zu verwenden,
dass die dauerhaft gegeben ist.
Das war ja die Idee von der Copyleft Lizenz, wo man sagt, ihr könnt das nutzen, ihr könnt das verändern,
ihr könnt es weitergeben und so weiter, alles könnt ihr machen, solange das, was ihr daraus entwickelt, unter derselben Lizenz steht.
Unter so einer Lizenz steht ja auch die Wikipedia zum Beispiel.
Und vor dem Internet hat das eh nicht wirklich abgehauen, da war ja eigentlich Richard Stallman und ein paar Freunde,
der hatte dann Disketten per Post durch das Land geschickt.
Und mit dem Internet war dann die technische Basis da, dass es sozusagen sich wirklich nochmal vervielfacht.
Und dadurch ist ja OpenSource eigentlich erst so richtig Mainstream geworden.
Und das ist auch deshalb so interessant, finde ich, weil normalerweise die Geschichte ist
und beim Radio war es ja auch so, oftmals entsteht was neues und das wird dann auch teilweise in nicht kommerziellen Kontexten,
an Unis und so, entwickelt und irgendwann kommt es dann in die Unternehmen, dann werden Produkte entwickelt
und dann wird das eingezäunt.
Dann kommt es zur sogenannten Kommodifizierung.
Dann werden Produkte draus gemacht und dann wird versucht, das auch zu schützen und alle, die quasi da das jetzt nicht so machen wollen,
die werden dann weggeklagt und eigentlich waren wir bei Software schon an dem Punkt.
Also OpenSource-Software wurde ja entwickelt zu einer Zeit, wie die größten Unternehmen der Welt,
Microsoft und Co entstanden sind, die quasi schon Software als Produkt eigentlich entwickelt hatten.
Windows war dann schon da bald und OpenSource ist erst gekommen, da war Microsoft die wertvollste Firma der Welt bereits,
mit Word und so weiter.
Und die enorme Leistung von OpenSource-Software und auch der Bewegung, die damit ausgelöst wurde, war eigentlich,
das Spiel nochmal zu öffnen und eigentlich dem klassischen kommodifizierten Produktkonzept,
das eigentlich schon da war und dominant war, ein, würde ich sage, zumindest stärker allmende,
also Commons-basierten Ansatz entgegenzustellen.
Und ich würde sagen, natürlich ist das hybrid.
Also wenn man sich anschaut, mein Android Smartphone, das hier vor mir auf dem Schreibtisch liegt,
ist auch irgendwie Linux, aber irgendwie auch Google.
Also da würde ich immer sagen, ja, es ist immer noch Kapitalismus.
Also da spielt Hierarchie natürlich eine Rolle, aber trotzdem würde ich sagen,
dass mir eine Android OpenSource-Welt, so kommerzialisiert sie auch sein mag, lieber ist,
als eine Windows- oder noch schlimmer irgendwie so iOS-Welt, wo quasi ganz zentralisierte Kontrolle herrscht.
Und das ist dieses Versprechen von Open Source einer Innovationsoffenheit und noch darüber hinaus,
nämlich Offenheit, nicht nur andere können innovativ sein, sondern auch einer Generativität,
so hat das, glaube ich, der Jonathan Zittrain mal für das Internet genannt,
also diese offene Lizenzen und diese Wissensallmende, die dadurch entsteht, zu der dann Leute auch beitragen kontinuierlich,
dass die eben nicht nur Innovation erlaubt, sondern Innovation sogar befördert, das Neue fördert.
Und ich würde sagen, das geht über alle Bereiche, nicht nur bei Software,
also mit Creative Commons hat es mich dann auch jenseits von Software interessiert.
Ich finde, ich bin auch ein großer Fan von Remix-Kunst und Kultur im weiteren Sinne,
wo eben das Neue aus der Rekombination von Bestehendem entsteht.
Okay, aber das ist ja eine gerechtfertigte Lobpreisung.
Die Frage ist ja jetzt, was hat das organisatorisch sozusagen bewirkt?
Also wodurch wurde das getragen, wodurch wurde das überhaupt möglich?
Nur, weil jetzt so zwei-drei Leute gesagt haben, ja hier Software kannst du benutzen etc., irgendwann wurde es eben auch groß.
Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die OpenSource-Welt da jetzt keine Probleme hätte.
Ja.
Also es gibt zahlreiche Beispiele populärer kleiner Tools, da ist dann irgendwie der Autor gestorben oder hatte keinen Bock mehr
oder hat sich mit irgendjemandem gestritten und dann gab es da irgendwie einen Projektsplit
und dann hat er das einfach mal vom Server genommen und dann zehn Minuten später brachen irgendwie hunderte von Servern im Internet zusammen,
weil die versucht haben, irgendsoein Modul, was schon immer da war, einfach mal so nachzuladen,
dann war das auf einmal nicht mehr da und irgendwie ihr kompletter Software-Stack funktionierte nicht mehr.
Wo dann die Leute gemerkt haben, oh ah unsere Organisation hat hier aber irgendwie ein Problem, weil ein für die Produktion
und riesige Umsätze und den Dauerbetrieb unserer Systeme ist auf einmal irgendein Typ,
der die letzten drei Jahre in der Unterhose vor seinem Rechner saß und irgendwie immer schön brav Return gedrückt hat,
absolut lebenswichtig, den kennen wir gar nicht, dem zahlen wir auch irgendwie gar nichts und jetzt ist er irgendwie nicht mehr da
und jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Ja und ich meine, das ist sicher aus Organisationsforschersicht besonders interessant gewesen am Anfang,
dass das nicht klar war, wie organisiert man das jetzt?
Also wie organisiert man das Verhältnis zwischen Community und Organisation?
Wie wird das funktionieren, wenn da manche bezahlt werden und andere nicht?
Die Antwort ist in dem Fall klar, bei Linux zum Beispiel 50% der Beiträge werden von bezahlten Entwicklern
und Entwicklerinnen beigesteuert, 50% nicht, so grob Daumenregel.
Es gibt viele OpenSource-Projekte, wo das inzwischen die Mehrheit der Beiträge von bezahlten Entwicklern kommen.
Wobei das ja oft dann Entwickler sind, die dann in die Unternehmen tatsächlich als Angestellte reingebracht werden
oder in welchem konkreten Vertragsverhältnis auch immer, aber sozusagen von den Unternehmen beschäftigt werden,
um dann mehr oder weniger weitgehend eigentlich das zu tun, was sie auch sonst getan haben.
Aber sie sind schon dann auch ans Unternehmen gebunden.
Ist nicht so sehr, dass jetzt das Geld in unabhängige Organisationen fließt.
Nein, das nicht, genau, nein gar nicht, das will ich gar nicht sagen.
Das wollte ich nur klarstellen.
Genau, ist eine gute Klarstellung.
Es ist eben nicht so, dass quasi dann nur, das merkt man ja auch an der Professionalisierung, die da passiert ist,
eben genau aus dieser Angst, die du geschildert hast, was ist, wenn der irgendwie keine Lust mehr hat
oder dem ein Ziegelstein auf den Kopf fällt, wie geht es dann weiter?
Und natürlich je unternehmenskritischer OpenSource-Software ist, umso mehr wollen die auch die Sicherheit haben,
dass diese Kernfunktionalität gewährleistet bleibt, egal was da draußen in der Community passiert.
Aber was man ja umgekehrt erkannt hat und was halt für die Unternehmen, warum sich OpenSource so durchgesetzt hat,
weil einfach der Punkt ist, Software ist einfach nicht ein Produkt, das mal fertig ist.
Software muss immer weiterentwickelt werden, das ist ja genau das, was du auch gesagt hast.
Ich kann da nicht mal aufhören, weil das muss immer weiter gepflegt werden.
Software as a Service, Software war schon ein Service, wie es noch als Produkt verkauft wurde.
Und OpenSource ist für diesen Ansatz besser geeignet aus mehreren Gründen.
Erstens lässt sich zumindest in dem Teil, der nicht wettbewerbsdifferenzierend ist für ein Unternehmen,
also so dieser Unterbau, das Langweilige, lassen sich Kosten einfach teilen, weil da können Wettbewerber auch entwickeln,
ist doch egal, wenn dieser quasi Unterbau, wenn wir uns da nicht unterscheiden, gut wenn der Mitbewerber auch mit zahlt.
Noch verrückter, wenn wir parallel beide dasselbe entwicklen, obwohl es uns nicht mal auseinanderhält.
Das ist mal das eine.
Das andere ist eben, dass es eben trotzdem passiert, dass bestimmte Dinge entwickelt werden von Dritten,
die vielleicht nicht mal Wettbewerber sind, aber die einfach das Tool in einem anderen Kontext einsetzen,
von dem ich wieder profitiere.
Und wenn ich das alles nur selber machen würde, würde es mich einfach mehr kosten.
Also es ist wirklich, es hat einerseits so eine Kostensenkungslogik aus einer Unternehmensperspektive
und eine Innovationslogik.
Andere sehen andere Dinge und eine Fehlerbereinigungslogik, also wobei da muss man sagen,
die Idee, dass OpenSource-Software fehlerfrei ist, ich glaube, die hat auch niemand mehr.
Ich glaube, die Idee, dass eine Software generell fehlerfrei sein kann, ist …
Genau, aber da muss man sagen, ich meine, du kennst ja sicher – das fand ich eigentlich ganz nett,
ich mag nicht alle Texte von ihm, er ist, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen crazy guy –
aber Paul Graham hat ja mal einen Aufsatz geschrieben, der dann auch der Titel einer Aufsatzsammlung von ihm wurde,
„Hackers and Painters“.
Und der Text hat mir sehr gut gefallen, den habe ich während meiner Dis gelesen.
Und was da so wirklich toll war und das bringt uns auch wieder zu dem Thema, was du vorher angesprochen hast,
und auf das ich sowieso nochmal zurückkommen wollte, weil das auch in meiner Forschung mich umtreibt,
eben diese Frage, wie geht man mit Fehlern um und wie antizipiert man Fehler?
Und dass quasi jeder Softwareansatz, der davon ausgeht, dass keine Fehler passieren dürfen, von vornherein zum Scheitern verurteilt ist.
Es wird Fehler geben.
Und die Frage ist nur, wie gehe ich damit um, kann ich sie korrigieren und wer darf sie finden?
Und da ist halt OpenSource einfach besser aufgestellt, weil einfach mehr Leute drauf schauen können,
zumindest potenziell, das tun am Ende nur wenige, aber ich muss auch sagen, und da sind wir auch noch,
Software ist inzwischen so bedeutsam für alle Aspekte unseres Lebens.
Wir sind ja komplett von Software umgeben.
Und es gibt eben diese zwei Ansätze, Security through Obscurity, also brauche ich dir nicht erklären
oder eben ein offener Ansatz und dieser Ansatz mit irgendwie so, ich muss drauf vertrauen,
dass irgendwie das schon ein paar Leute eh gut gemacht haben, das, glaube ich, wurde zu oft erschüttert,
nicht erst durch Snowden.
Und das heißt, insofern gibt es da, glaube ich, sehr viele …
Wobei der Ansatz, dass Fehler schon gefunden werden, wenn genug Leute drauf schauen, der wurde nun auch schon mehrfach erschüttert.
Und das ist ja auch, wo wir ja auch nochmal draufkommen können, auch bei der Wikipedia nicht im Bereich Software,
sondern im Bereich Wissen auch ein Problem.
Wobei damit würde ich zum Beispiel einhalten wollen und sagen, das ist eigentlich der Treppenwitz der Internetgeschichte,
wie die Wikipedia wahrgenommen wird.
Wenn man sich anschaut, Wikipedia 2001 gegründet und die ersten zehn Jahre war die Diskussion vor allem eine,
kann man das glauben, was da drin steht?
Ich mein, da kann jeder ran.
Also die Klassiker, Guttenberg kriegt einen zusätzlichen Vornamen und eine Insel ist drin, die nicht existiert.
Und das Schöne ist, warum weiß ich diese Beispiele alle?
Es gibt in der Wikipedia einen Wikipedia-Artikel zu Wikipedia Hoaxes,
wo quasi schön aufgelistet wird, welche Falschmeldungen es wie lange in der Wikipedia quasi überlebt haben.
Wenn das mal stimmt.
Genau und das ist sehr gut, das ist ein super Punkt.
Das zeigt nämlich, dass wir …
Ich will jetzt nicht zu pathetisch kommen, ja, aber für mich hat das natürlich trotzdem eine sokratische Logik.
Also ich habe als Kind bei „Es war einmal der Mensch“, werde ich nie vergessen, Sokrates, der irgendwie so einem kleinen Buben sagt,
was weißt du Kleiner?
Und der Kleine sagt, nichts, und Sokrates sagt, dann weißt du schon eine ganze Menge,
also dieses, ich weiß, dass ich nichts weiß.
Ich habe es nie ganz verstanden was das heißt, bis mir irgendwann viel später bei Popper-Lektüre
und so Wissenschaftstheorie, eigentlich muss man es ja lesen als, ich weiß, dass ich nichts mit Sicherheit weiß.
Es gibt kein sicheres Wissen, gibt es nicht, ich habe den infiniten Regress.
Und da finde ich Wikipedia wieder so schön, weil das das so deutlich macht.
Es ist einfach klar, Wissen ist immer vorläufig, es ist nie hundertprozentig sicher
und es ist immer Ergebnis von kollektivem Wirken und genau das ist jedem in der Wikipedia völlig klar,
aber es gilt für jede Form von Wissen.
Und da ist es unfassbar aufklärerisch, finde ich.
Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will ist diese Geschichte.
Also die ersten zehn Jahre war das die Diskussion und dann gab es immer diese Studien,
ist die Wikipedia besser oder schlechter als die Encyclopedia Britannica oder so?
Das war schnell entschieden, das hat nicht lange gedauert, bis die dicht machen musste.
Und dann hat sich das aber irgendwie gedreht.
Und heute ist es eher so, wenn wir heute im Zeitalter von Fake News, Desinformation und Verschwörungstheorien leben,
wenn man sich anschaut, was haben Facebook und YouTube, die beiden größten Verschwörungstheorieschleudern dieses Planeten,
was war deren Reaktion auf zunehmende Kritik?
Ihr Response war, okay in Zukunft bei fragwürdigen Artikeln verlinke wir auf die Wikipedia.
Ich meine, diesen Twist muss man hinkriegen.
Die ersten zehn Jahre, da kann man nichts glauben, kann jeder alles reinschreiben
und zehn Jahre später, die einzige vertrauenswürdige Quelle im Netz, die wir noch haben, ist Wikipedia.
Und ich würde sagen, das ist aber kein Zufall und da kommen wir wieder zur Organisation zurück.
Weil natürlich Wikipedia von Anfang an ein Fake News Problem hatte.
Da konnte eben wirklich von Anfang an jeder alles reinschreiben, also musste man mit diesem Problem
von Desinformation, Verschwörungstheorie oder auch Werbung und Propaganda von Anfang an umgehen.
Und das heißt, da hat sich viel geändert zum Guten wie zum Schlechten.
Aber sozusagen Wikipedia ist sehr robust gegen Falschinformation heute.
Es gibt Vandalenjäger, die Vandalismus bekämpfen, so dass sie niemand mitbekommt.
Wer heute auf die Wikipedia schaut und nicht eingeloggt ist, der sieht gar nicht die letzte Variante,
sondern der sieht die letzte Variante, die jemand mit Sichtungsrechten quasi freigegeben hat,
das wissen die meisten Leute gar nicht.
Da hat sich viel getan an Regeln.
Also wir haben ja vorher über Tesla gesprochen, die hatten ja so ein Handbuch,
wo drin steht, eigentlich Regeln haben wir keine hier so.
Wikipedia hatte auch am Anfang so den Spruch, ich glaube, irgendwo in der Wikipedia findet man den noch,
„ignore all rules“, also ignoriere alle Regeln.
Heute kann man da wirklich nur noch weinen, wenn man sich das vor Augen hält,
weil was dieser Versuch quasi, glaubwürdiges nachvollziehbares Wissen zu produzieren eigentlich …
Wie hat man das versucht zu erreichen?
Mit einer Regelexplosion.
Also es gibt heute so viele Regeln in der Wikipedia, dass es immer schwieriger wird Artikel unterzubringen.
Ich frage immer in meiner Lehrveranstaltung zu Beginn meine Studierenden,
hat jemand von euch schon mal Wikipedia editiert?
Meistens zeigen ein-zwei Leute auf, nie mehr, egal wie groß die Gruppe.
Das ist dann entweder, ich habe einen Tippfehler korrigiert oder ich habe einmal versucht was reinzuschreiben,
wurde sofort wieder gelöscht.
Also das ist quasi die heutige Geschichte, es ist ganz schwer, einen Artikel in der Wikipedia unterzukriegen,
weil es diese vielen neuen Regeln gibt, weil diese Community natürlich auch total gebranntes Kind ist,
was betrifft, dass Leute dort ihre Produkte promoten wollen, ihr Unternehmen in ein rechtes Licht rücken wollen,
dass Politiker ihre Einträge schönen und so weiter und so weiter.
Aber man sieht eben, dass trotzdem dieser Zwang zu einem Konsens auf einen Artikel,
dass auch unterschiedliche polarisierende Meinungen da irgendwie dann das ausstreiten müssen,
und wenn es lange dauert und auch nicht endgültig ist, dass das zu robusteren Ergebnissen führt
als YouTube und Facebook, wo sich die einzelnen, ich würde nicht sagen Filterbubbles, weil die gibt es ja nicht,
aber diese Tribes, die sich ihrer Meinung wechselseitig versichern, sich auch nichts einigen müssen,
sondern in ihren Parallelwelt vor sich hin quasi twittern, youtuben und facebooken.
Ja, also das ist ein guter Punkt mit der Resilienz.
Ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, ich hatte 2004 mal eine Sendung gemacht über die Wikipedia, als es noch keiner kannte
und da hatten wir da sozusagen live on air, also in einer Live-Radiosendung sozusagen tatsächlich genauso diese Debatte,
was da kann jeder jetzt irgendwas ändern, das mache ich jetzt mal.
Und dann kam man gar nicht so weit, weil es zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil es ja alles live ausgestrahlt wurde,
andere dann schon getan hatten und dann entsprang also wirklich live während dieser Sendung so ein Edit-War
um diesen Artikel, an dem man einfach sehr schön in dem Moment sehen konnte, wie im Kleinen dann eben diese Prozesse reingehen.
Und damit ist das ein guter Punkt, habe ich so noch gar nicht gesehen, das ist sozusagen die Genese von Wikipedia.
Also sie sind groß geworden mit diesem Umstand und haben von daher relativ früh und vor vielen anderen Sachen,
die man vielleicht als wichtig erachten würde, hier entsprechende Mechanismen entwickelt, die sich dann eben auch in einer Community verfestigt haben,
also quasi die Organisation auch geprägt haben, weil Dinge dann auf einmal früh wichtig wurden,
wo andere eben das sozusagen das Problem nie hatten und jetzt nicht mehr in der Lage sind,
sich einer wechselnden Öffentlichkeitswelt entsprechend entgegenzustellen,
weil man einfach, ja so haben wir da nie drüber nachgedacht und alles ist sozusagen anders gebaut,
alles ist gebaut mit dieser Idee, dass wir da irgendwie eine klare Hierarchie und eine Kontrolle haben.
Und wir wissen mehr.
Also der Klassiker, ich habe es erwähnt, ich blogge sehr viel über netzpolitik.org und ich finde,
einer der Taglines von Netzpolitik, die ich immer schon cool fand, war, uns liegen Dokumente nicht nur vor,
wir veröffentlichen sie auch.
Und das finde ich deshalb so cool, weil bis heute die anderen normalen Onlinemedien, Tageszeitungen im Netz,
whatever, Spiegel online immer sagen, nach dem Spiegel vorliegenden Informationen,
aber dass das natürlich … ja da muss ich denen halt glauben, dass die nicht selektiv zitieren.
Also wir natürlich bei Netzpolitik sind bekannt dafür, dass da die Artikel auch klare Positionierung und Haltung haben,
aber wenn du eine andere Meinung hast, lies selber nach, bilde dir deine eigene Meinung, hier ist das Dokument.
Und das ist halt auch was, wie Wikipedia das organisatorisch macht, ein wesentlicher Teil ist radikale Transparenz.
Jede Änderung ist dauerhaft nachvollziehbar.
Das heißt nicht, dass Manipulation dort nicht möglich ist, natürlich wird manipuliert.
Natürlich gerade weil Wikipedia so einflussreich ist, ich meine, ist die einzige nichtkommerzielle Webseite
unter den 50 meistbesuchten Seiten im Netz und jeder, der einen Wikipedia-Eintrag hat,
du hast auch einen, der weiß, wie stark das framed, wie Leute einen wahrnehmen, die einen nicht kennen.
Weil das erste, was sie gelesen haben, ist dein Wikipedia-Eintrag und bei mir stehen da auch vier Bücher drin,
wo ich mir denke, ja also das wichtigste in meinem Feld sind wissenschaftliche Artikel.
Die Bücher ja, die sind so Abfallprodukte eher, die gab es auch, aber die sind jetzt nicht so wichtig,
aber Artikel wird keiner zitiert.
Gut, aber da ist es halt so, dass quasi hier dieser Transparenzansatz eben viel, würde ich sagen, resilienter ist
in diesem neuen digitalen Spiel als diese klassische, wir haben einen privilegierten Zugang zu Wissen
und jetzt geben wir euch netterweise ein bisschen ein paar Wissensbrosamen ab.
Jetzt hast du es ja am Anfang auch schon mal angesprochen, deswegen will ich es jetzt auch nochmal aufgreifen,
finde ich an der Stelle auch relativ wichtig,
bei Wikipedia hat man natürlich so ein bisschen das Problem, so ein Diversitätsproblem.
Es ist also strukturell alles so geboren worden aus einer stark männlich geprägten Sicht.
Man könnte halt auch sagen, männlich weiß, also privilegiert, Leute mit Zugang zu Technologie, Leute, die auch Zeit haben,
die sozusagen da auch viel Zeit haben reinversenken können.
Ich hatte auch mal so eine Phase, was weiß ich, ich habe mal wochenlang einfach nur Wikipedia-Artikel editiert,
weiß gar nicht, hunderte von Edits, einfach um es mal gemacht zu haben, einfach um da Erfahrungen zu haben,
auch den ein oder anderen mal angelegt, so alles mal gemacht, dann war das für mich dann aber auch irgendwann gut.
Um da sozusagen dabei zu bleiben, braucht es natürlich schon so eine spezifische Motivation.
Da gab es dann so Leute, die waren in gewisser Hinsicht prädestiniert.
Die waren ohnehin in ihrem Feld gut, studierten gerade, also waren eh in so einem Forschungsmodus
und Wissen-anlern-Modus und haben dann quasi die Wikipedia auch vielleicht für sich als Werkzeug benutzt,
wie so ein Notizbuch sozusagen und dabei eben auch einfach andere Techniken erlernt
oder waren halt auch ohnehin so im wissenschaftlichen Schreiben unterwegs.
Keine Ahnung, gab tausend Gründe, warum Leute sich motiviert gefühlt haben.
Teilweise weil sie auch einfach Teil so einer neuen Community sein wollten, irgendwann war es dann vielleicht nicht mehr so spannend.
Andere Dinge sind passiert in ihrem Leben, weg waren sie.
Jetzt ist natürlich für so eine lose Gemeinschaft sehr schwierig, da einen Deckel drauf zu kriegen und zu sagen,
wir müssen jetzt hier in irgendeiner Form unsere Tradition, unsere Resilienz sozusagen,
aber auch unsere Motivation aufrecht erhalten.
Das heißt, wir sind schon in gewisser Hinsicht jetzt hier auch im Besitzstandswahrungsmodus,
aber wir müssen uns auch nochmal komplett neuen Anforderungen öffnen, weil wir eben bisher auch, sagen wir mal,
die Weltsicht, die wir ja eigentlich darstellen wollen, so auch so umfangreich noch gar nicht darstellen.
Was beobachtest du da, wie die Wikipedia als Projekt damit umgeht und haben sie damit Erfolg?
Also erstens würde ich sagen, diese Frage von, bei mir läuft das derzeit … und das ist, würde ich sagen, etwas,
wo ich gerade unmittelbar derzeit am intensivsten dazu forsche, weil ich es interessant finde
und weil es auch einen veränderten Blick auf Offenheit als Ideal widerspiegelt, den man auch beobachten kann.
Also ich würde sagen, diese oftmals Euphorie, die man auch im Nachgang des OpenSource Erfolgs
so Anfang der 2000er Jahre ja hatte, ich finde, die ist ein bisschen abgeflaut.
Und diese Desinformationskisten, die ja auch mit einer großen Offenheit dieser neuen digitalen Plattformen teilweise zu tun haben,
auch wenn die proprietär sind, die zahlt da sicher ein drauf.
Aber dieses, was eben durchaus ein Thema ist und das eben nicht nur bei der Wikipedia, sondern auch bei OpenSource-Software so,
ist etwas, was ich exkludierende Offenheit nennen würde.
Ich möchte es kurz erklären, was ich damit meine.
Also bei Wikipedia steht auf der englischen Seite immer noch drunter, the Encyclopedia that anyone can edit.
Also alle können mitarbeiten.
Prinzipiell gilt das auch für OpenSource-Software, da ist natürlich die Hürde größer.
Ich muss mal überhaupt programmieren können.
Aber ich fange mal bei OpenSource an, weil da ist das älter und da merkt man,
das Problem ist eben durchaus eines, das gibt es in vielen Bereichen, wo die Leute sagen, alle können mitmachen,
ja aber dann kommen ganz spezielle Leute nur.
Also in der US-Software-Industrie sind rund 20% Frauen Entwickler.
Also klar, da gibt es auch einen Bias.
Aber in der OpenSource-Software-Szene sind es zwischen 2 und 5 Prozent.
Also viel weniger als es quasi am Pool wäre.
Also das ist schon eine Frage, die muss man stellen, was ist der Grund dafür?
Und in der Wikipedia nicht so ein ganz krasses Missverhältnis, andererseits muss man sagen,
Wikipedia hat eigentlich mit den Themen alle Themen dieser Welt.
Warum sollte es überhaupt einen Bias geben und seitdem es quasi auch den Visual Editor gibt,
der ist Standard inzwischen, kann ich Wikipedia so leicht editieren wie ein Word Dokument,
zumindest wenn es nur um Text geht.
Und trotzdem ist es so, dass erstens unter 20 Prozent in der deutschen und englischen Wikipedia nur weiblich sind,
dass die Anzahl der Autorinnen und Autoren seit über zehn Jahren stagniert und sinkt.
Also in der deutschsprachigen Wikipedia gibt es derzeit nur halb so viele regelmäßig aktiv beitragende wie vor zehn Jahren.
Was auch bedeutet, dass man nicht sagen kann, okay das kommt halt aus dieser Nerd-Ecke, da waren halt nur Typen,
aber das wächst sich aus.
Also das könnte man ja meinen.
Ja gut, also je mehr Leute die Wikipedia lesen, alle Männer und Frauen lesen die zu gleichen Teilen,
über das Lesen stolpert man dann irgendwie rein und dann wird sich das schon ausmitteln.
Also diese Hoffnung ist definitiv over.
Also das passiert nicht.
Im Gegenteil, man hat manchmal das Gefühl es verschärft sich noch.
Und es gibt ganz viel Forschung dazu, nicht von mir, von anderen, selbst auch ein bisschen dazu geforscht.
Aber es gibt viele Gründe natürlich, also einerseits kann man sagen, Wikipedia ist ein Spiegelbild der Gesellschaft.
Wie du selbst gesagt hast, man braucht Zeit.
Jetzt kann man sagen, der männliche Student, dessen Mutter noch die Wäsche macht und ihn bekocht,
hat mehr Zeit, in der Wikipedia zu schreiben, als eben diese Mutter.
Also ja, man kann sagen, bestimmte Reproduktionsarbeitsungleichheiten spiegeln sich in der Wikipedia.
Umgekehrt könnte man eben wieder sagen, es ist aber nicht so, dass Frauen weniger ehrenamtlich engagiert wären.
Also es gibt halt, obwohl Frauen mehr Hausarbeit machen, im ehrenamtlichen Engagement sind halt andere Dinge.
Es gibt verschiedene andere Gründe, dass Wikipedia halt technisch ist und das halt weniger und so weiter.
Ich würde sagen, einer der robustesten Gründe dafür ist aber schon etwas, das man vielleicht so eine Art männlich geprägte Kultur nennen könnte,
die sich einfach herausgebildet hat, da sind wir wieder auch bei der Pfadabhängigkeit.
Insofern stimmt es schon, dass es damit zu tun hat, dass da am Anfang ein Männerüberhang war,
aber das hat sich insofern verschärft, und ich finde, man kann das auch ganz gut nachvollziehen, warum das so ist
und so schwer ist zu ändern.
Die Valerie Aurora hat das mal für OpenSource-Software gesagt, das ist mein Lieblingszitat,
ich verwende es auch für Wikipedia, sie hat gesagt, wenn du eine Gruppe hast aus zehn Typen,
und davon sind neun höflich, hilfsbereit, nett und wirklich zuvorkommend und einer ist ein Jerk, würde man im Englischen sagen,
einer ist ein sexistischer Belästiger, dann werden die Frauen wegen dem einen Typen wegbleiben.
Die neun netten können gar nichts machen.
Wenn die diesen Typen tolerieren, dann werden die Frauen wegbleiben aus guten Gründen.
Warum soll ich mich belästigen lassen in meiner Freizeit?
Habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Damit sind wir bei der exkludierende Offenheit.
Es gibt den Spruch, ich glaube auch in Deutschland, wer für alles offen ist, ist nicht ganz dicht.
So ein bisschen ist das da auch.
Wenn ich sage, jeder darf bei mir mitmachen und dieses jeder erstreckt sich auch auf Leute, die andere vertreiben,
dann habe ich ein Problem.
So und jetzt, warum ist das so schwierig, da Konsequenzen draus zu ziehen?
Für die Wikipedia gibt es zwei, die haben beide mit Organisation zu tun.
Das eine ist, die Wikimedia Foundation, die quasi seit 15 Jahren versucht, mehr Frauen in die Wikipedia zu bringen,
die kann nicht Regeln für Aus- und Einschlüsse ändern, weil ganz bewusst sie sagt,
das ist eine Sache der Community, wir halten uns da raus.
Das ist eine Ideologie, die sehr stark verankert ist, an der zu rütteln, glaube ich, Sinn machen würde,
aber das ist diese Trennung zwischen formaler Organisation und Community.
Wikimedia mischt sich nicht ein, die Community entscheidet ganz autonom darüber, was in der Wikipedia steht,
welche Relevanzkriterien und wer wie ausgeschlossen wird, so.
Das ist das eine, das müsste man, glaube ich, ein bisschen durchbrechen.
Da bräuchte man, Geld ist da, die Wikimedia sitzt auf über hundert Millionen Dollar an Reserven, also die haben Kohle.
Aber sie wissen gar nicht, wie sie es gut genug ausgeben können.
Also ich finde zum Beispiel, jedes Tageszeitungsforum hat bezahlte Moderatorinnen und Moderatoren,
weil es sonst komplett aus dem Ruder laufen würde, aber die größte Enzyklopädie der Welt braucht so was nicht.
Also das ist schon mal ein Thema.
Und das zweite Thema ist halt wirklich, und das ist viel schwieriger noch anzugehen, wenn man sagt,
wieder bei diesem Beispiel bleiben, zehn Administratoren, neun sind hilfsbereit und super und einer ist ein Problem.
Jetzt sind da aber Leute, die in der Wikipedia Administrator sind, die haben meistens eine jahrelange, jahrzehntelange Geschichte.
Die haben tausend Artikel geschrieben, unfassbar viel beigetragen.
Da überlegst du schon nicht einmal oder zweimal, ob du so eine Person wirklich rauswirfst, weil er halt mal unhöflich war
oder da mal irgendwie…
Also die haben erstens viele Freunde und die haben auch einen Track Record, die haben gezeigt, sie sind bereit,
jahrelang ihre gesamte Freizeit in das Projekt zu investieren.
Und das ist bei OpenSource ja auch ähnlich.
Leute, die dort quasi viel investiert haben und viel programmiert haben und jetzt sage ich,
tut mir leid, aber das geht so nicht, den hauen wir jetzt raus, aber vielleicht kommt nie eine Frau, die seinen Job nimmt
oder irgendwer anderer.
Also die Frage ist, das ist ein großes Risiko auch für die Community zu sagen, jetzt sind wir da strenger und werfen solche Leute raus.
Wir wissen aber nicht, ob Leute kommen, um die zu ersetzen.
Also da ist man natürlich, da zögert man, aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen und das sind harte Entscheidungen.
Also wo ziehe ich die Grenze, wie hart setze ich die durch?
Und reicht das schon oder kommen die dann trotzdem nicht, auch wenn ich jetzt da zum Beispiel vier, fünf Leuten mal gesagt habe,
das geht so nicht.
Also das ist wirklich ein Problem.
Ich sage nicht, dass es eine einfache Lösung gibt.
Aus meiner Lektüre der Forschung, also meine Empfehlung wäre eben zu sagen, lasst uns mal bezahlte hauptamtliche Communitymanagerinnen einführen,
die einfach sich drum kümmern, quasi bestehende Regeln zu policen und sich um neue anzunehmen.
Ich glaube, wirklich vor allem Hauptaufgabe, den Umgangston und das Klima quasi zu verbessern.
Aber ich sage, es gibt keine Garantie, dass das funktioniert.
Aber ich muss eh sagen, wenn das so weitergeht, irgendwann wird die Wikimedia vielleicht dazu übergehen müssen,
sogar die Autorinnen zu bezahlen, weil wenn so wenig Freiwillige da sind, aber immer mehr Spenden eingesammelt werden,
also irgendwann gibt es vielleicht einen spendenfinanzierte Wikipedia, aber finanziert im Sinne von,
auch die Texte werden dann halt von Staff-Writern gemacht.
Ich weiß es nicht, das wäre für mich jetzt keine Vision, wo ich sagen würde, gut,
aber ich würde auch sagen, die Wikipedia wird es geben, aber ob quasi dieses Konzept, alles komplett freiwillig,
ob das dauerhaft trägt, bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Das ist natürlich ein Problem von allen freiwilligen Organisationen, gerade die, die versuchen so ein bisschen das Bessere der Welt zu repräsentieren,
dass in dem Moment, wo man sich eben bezahlte Mitarbeiter reinholt, man eben sofort dann auch die Nachteile sich eintritt,
die mit so was verbunden sind, so Leute, die dann so einen Posten erst mal haben, tun dann natürlich auch alles dafür,
ihn zu behalten, weil das bezahlt einen ja auch, das macht einen in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch so ein bisschen faul,
man hat auf einmal ganz andere Prioritäten.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein generelles Problem, was einfach schwierig zu lösen ist.
Gibt es denn irgendwelche anderen GOs, NGOs, Organisationsformen, die an der Stelle irgendwie Erfolg gehabt haben und ein Modell sein könnten?
Also ich würde so sagen, alle freiwilligen Organisationen kämpfen mit diesem Spannungsverhältnis aus Hauptamtlichen und Ehrenamtlichen.
Das ist, sobald ich die, wie du sagst, aber das tut die Wikipedia jetzt schon, es gibt ja jetzt schon ganz viel Staff in der Wikimedia.
Die machen halt nur Softwareentwicklung und so.
Aber natürlich gibt es da auch immer wieder Konflikte.
Ja, also wenn die Wikimedia wieder verklagt wird oder so, dann irgendwas in der Wikipedia geändert werden muss,
dann führt das auch schon zu Problemen.
Also dieses Spannungsverhältnis gibt es sowieso, aber du hast völlig recht, das ist jetzt nicht so,
dass das mit der Wikipedia erst entstanden worden wäre.
Irgendwann mal haben die Wikipedianer selbst sich verglichen mit dem Roten Kreuz und haben gesagt,
wir sind das Rote Kreuz für das Weltwissen.
Ja, beim Roten Kreuz haben wir das auch, da haben wir die ganzen Freiwilligen, die quasi da eben Rettungsdienst machen
und es gibt die Hauptamtlichen und die machen auch teilweise denselben Job.
Da gibt es die Hauptamtlichen und da gibt es die Freiwilligen und die machen denselben Job.
Und was die Wikimedia-Leute eh jetzt schon machen ist eben zu sagen, wir wollen die Freiwilligen supporten,
unsere Hauptaufgabe ist Community-Support.
Das Problem ist aber da halt, wenn die Community schon so geschrumpft ist und so einen bestimmten Charakter hat,
dann irgendwann gibt es Grenzen von dem, wo die Erneuerungsfähigkeit aus der Community raus nicht funktionieren wird.
Aber insofern glaube ich, das Spannungsverhältnis wegzukriegen, das ist unmöglich.
Das ist aber überhaupt was, wenn wir wieder ins Allgemeine zurückgehen, es gibt in Organisationen Widersprüche,
die kann ich bearbeiten, dafür kann ich Räume und Orte schaffen, diese Widersprüche immer wieder zu behandeln,
aber die kriege ich nicht weg.
Also es ist Freiwillige und Hauptamtliche in Freiwilligenorganisationen, das ist Arbeit und Kapital im Unternehmen,
und ich kann das auf unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen lösen.
Ich kann sagen, ich habe quasi Betriebsräte und ich habe eine Betriebsverfassungsgesetz und die sitzen sogar im Aufsichtsrat,
so wie man das in Deutschland und in Österreich gemacht hat, oder ich kann sagen wie in den USA,
nein, das machen wir auf keinen Fall, dann gibt es die Konflikte auch, aber dann gibt es viel mehr Streiks,
weil dann sind das halt quasi die Gewerkschaften, dann wird halt quasi, wenn man sich das nicht vorher ausmachen kann im Aufsichtsrat,
dann wird es halt auf der Straße ausgehandelt, so quasi.
Also den Widerspruch gibt es, den kriege ich auch mit Mitbestimmung nicht weg.
Er wird nur anders behandelt und das kann Vor- und Nachteile haben.
Manchmal führt das dazu, dass es Co-Management gibt und Dinge irgendwie durchgesetzt werden,
weil die Gewerkschaften eingekauft sind, auch dafür kennen wir in Deutschland Beispiel, VW.
Also diese Sachen haben wir.
Das ist Arbeit – Kapitel, Freiwillige – Professionelle, Flexibilität und Stabilität oder Innovation und Effizienz,
das sind alles so Spannungsverhältnisse, da kann ich mich mal auf die ein oder auf die andere Seite schlagen,
aber sie werden mich immer wieder einholen.
Und das ist auch gut für mich, weil deshalb wird Organisationsforschung quasi immer gebraucht werden.
/lacht/ Da klappt es dann auf jeden Fall mit der Besitzstandswahrung.
Genau.
Ja, vielleicht zum Schluss, gibt es denn noch jenseits dessen, was wir besprochen haben, interessante Entwicklungen,
die gerade auffallen in der Forschung, wo sich neue Strukturen oder neue Strukturbildungsmechanismen zeigen,
die vielleicht interessant wären, sich in der nächsten Zeit mal genauer anzuschauen?
Gibt es irgendwelche Trends jenseits des Internets, die sich herausbilden, die irgendwie eine besondere Resilienz oder einen besonderen Erfolg gezeigt haben?
Also das ist jetzt wirklich zum Abschluss, da habe ich so getan, als könnte ich alles beantworten,
aber diese Frage ist wirklich schwer.
Erst mal zu, wo beginnt denn das Neue?
Ich würde sagen, da habe ich natürlich einen Bias, mich interessieren die Netzthemen, da bin ich zu Hause.
Also ich würde sagen, so jenseits des Internets mag schon sein, aber im Internet habe ich das noch nicht mitbekommen.
Ich würde eher sagen, man merkt schon, welche Zyklen es da auch gibt.
Also dass bestimmte Fragen wieder neu gestellt werden
oder sich Probleme quasi wieder neu stellen, die man eigentlich schon überwunden geglaubt hat.
Also wenn wir jetzt so anschauen, was da in Ungarn und Osteuropa teilweise passiert, wie quasi es zu einer Reautoritarisierung kommt,
also wie wir das Mediensystem dort aufstellen, also das würde ich sagen.
Oder auch in der Türkei, das ist ja nicht weit weg von uns.
Und in Österreich, würde ich sagen, hatte die letzte Regierung, die wir hatten, ähnliche Pläne.
Jetzt ist das gerade mal wieder so eine Pause, mal schauen.
Also ich würde eher sagen, wir haben es hier mit organisationalen Moden, mit Zyklen zu tun
und da ist es eher wichtig, glaube ich, die immer wieder auch im historischen Kontext einzubetten und zu schauen,
vielleicht ist nicht alles ganz neu und vielleicht ist eben das, was heute unter Agilität läuft,
selbststeuernde Teams mit Digitalunterstützung.
Und ich glaube, was wir auch am Anfang besprochen hatten, was mir eben da so wichtig wäre,
immer auf die Kontingenz zu pochen.
Also es mag schon sein, dass das gut funktioniert, aber das heißt nicht, dass es anders nicht genau so gut oder sogar noch besser funktionieren könnte.
Also das Wissen, dass man nichts weiß?
Na das Wissen, dass man nichts sicher weiß.
Nichts sicher weiß, okay.
Und das Wissen um Alternativen.
Also vielleicht mein Lieblingszitat, was ich aus Berlin mit nach Innsbruck gebracht habe.
An der FU Berlin im wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen Fachbereich da gibt es in den Gängen,
wo die Studierenden gehen, im Hörsaalgebäude gibt es innen so eine Aluleiste über den Hörsälen,
da sind Sprüche eingraviert, also ausgeschnitten eigentlich und beleuchtet, sehr schick.
Und mein Lieblingsspruch dort ist, das hört sich trivial an, aber wenn man länger darüber nachdenkt,
dann nimmt man da viel mit, ist, „the map ist not the territory“.
Also die Landkarte ist nicht das Gelände.
Und das hat zwei wichtige Lektionen für mich.
Also das erste ist mal, also gerade aus einer wissenschaftlichen Perspektive, wie man auf Organisationen und wie man auf die Welt schaut.
Eine Landkarte ist immer eine Vereinfachung.
Ich muss quasi Dinge ausblenden, aber das ist nicht ein Bug, das ist ein Feature.
Ich kann mit einer 1:1-Landkarte, die hilft mir nicht bei der Orientierung.
Ich brauche also eine Landkarte, die Dinge vereinfacht, ausblendet, die quasi falsch ist.
Jede Landkarte ist falsch, weil sie Dinge ganz krass ausblendet und nicht berücksichtigt.
Und nur deshalb funktioniert sie, aber auch nur deshalb kann sie Orientierung geben.
Das ist sozusagen das eine, die eine Lektion von the map is not the territory,
aber die andere und die scheint mir mindestens so wichtig und die wird oft vergessen,
ich brauche mehr als eine Karte, gerade weil sie falsch ist und weil sie nicht überall funktioniert.
Deshalb habe ich eine Wanderkarte, wenn ich mich in den Tiroler Bergen bewege.
Ich habe eine Autobahnkarte, wenn ich mit dem Auto unterwegs bin.
Es gibt eine Luftkarte für Flugzeuge, es gibt eine Seekarte für Schiffe.
Und das heißt, selbst wenn ich im selben Gelände bin, können je nach Gefährt oder je nach Fortbewegungsmittel,
brauche ich andere Karten.
Und damit ist für mich eine inhärente Pluralismusmessage drin.
Ich brauche mehr als eine Theorie.
Und jetzt darf ich mein best of an Zitaten hier loswerden, mein Lieblingszitat von Popper ist,
„wenn du glaubst, dass eine Theorie die einzig mögliche ist, um ein Problem zu lösen,
dann hast du weder die Theorie noch das Problem verstanden.“
Und das ist zum Beispiel, also was ich meinen Studierenden mitgeben will, weil ich immer sage,
warum quäle ich euch mit fünf verschiedenen Ansätzen, wie man Organisation theoretisieren kann,
warum müsst ihr euch das anhören?
Und ich sage, schaut Leute, jetzt findet ihr das mühsam, aber wenn ihr dann in einem Unternehmen seid,
dann habt ihr Probleme und dann kann ich natürlich die Hammermethode haben und everything looks like a nail, draufkloppen,
aber manchmal brauche ich vielleicht eine Kreissäge.
Also es ist einfach, das kann ich aber nur, wenn mir klar ist, es gibt immer auch andere theoretische Blickwinkel,
die vielleicht dann zu anderen oder auch zu denselben Ergebnissen führen.
Ja, also das ist, glaube ich, was wichtig ist.
Wenn man sagt, es gibt ein neues Phänomen, schaut mal, es gibt mehr als eine Metapher für diese neuen Phänomene
und wahrscheinlich ist es sowieso ein Remix von irgendwas, was schon da ist, das aber dann doch wieder ganz anders funktionieren kann.
Und das betrifft auch ganz viele dieser neuen agilen Organisationsformen, wo ich sage,
ja da kommen so Klassiker des Selbstorganisationsansatzes kommen zusammen mit neuen Formen
des vielleicht digitalen Neotaylorismus.
Und da eine Balance zu finden, die eben dann wirklich empowerned ist, ist gar nicht so leicht.
Und da auch wieder der Klassiker, jede formale Organisation hat auch informale Organisation
und die kann teilweise wichtiger oder restringierender sein.
Und das sind alles Klassiker der Organisationsforschung, die ich aber in diesen neuen Kontexten mitdenken müsste.
Also insofern, wenn ich jetzt auf deine Frage dann doch irgendwie antworten würde, würde ich sagen,
nur weil da viel Neues passiert, kann es trotzdem Sinn machen, ein paar so Klassiker zu lesen
und so sich ein buntes Werkzeugset quasi zurechtzulegen.
Aber vor allem muss man sich immer die Ist-Situation anschauen und nach Maßgabe vor Ort entscheiden,
weil es gibt keinen allgemeinen Ansatz, mit dem man dann sagen könnte, nur so, wenn das man das so organisiert, geht das und sonst geht das nicht.
Genau. Und ich meine, auch da ist Wikipedia wieder so ein schönes Beispiel.
Ich meine, wie soll das funktionieren?
Freiwillige, kein Geschäftsmodell, mit einer Webseite, die wirklich aus den 90ern ist.
Also ich meine, das ist schon erstaunlich eigentlich, allein dass sie existieren.
Aber auch das finde ich schön, dass es bei allen Problemen, die wir ja auch diskutiert haben,
ist sie trotzdem so der Stachel im Fleisch der Leute, die sagen, man kann das sowieso alles nur kommerziell organisieren.
Und vielleicht das haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen, das, finde ich, muss ich hier noch loswerden,
wo auch zum Beispiel meine Wikipedia-Forschung, ohne dass das geplant war, mit meiner Fernsehratstätigkeit total zusammenkommt.
Ja, weil wenn an sich anschaut, die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen spielen ihre Inhalte teilweise auf kommerziellen Plattformen
wie YouTube und Facebook aus, also in einem Umfeld, wo die Frage ist.
Ich bin nicht dagegen, ich sage, kein Facebook und kein YouTube ist keine Lösung,
weil eben die jungen Leute dort sind, aber es gibt bislang kaum Inhalte der öffentlich-rechtlichen Anstalten auf Wikipedia,
wo eigentlich das viel naheliegender wäre, Wikipedia vor allem Text und Bild, haben keine Videos,
weil das ist teuer und aufwändig zu produzieren.
Die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen haben ganz viel Material, das sich eigentlich unter einer freien Lizenz veröffentlichen ließe.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht alles was GEMA-Musik, Agenturmaterial oder Fiction ist scheidet aus,
also kein Tatort wird jemals auf der Wikipedia landen, ist auch Wurscht.
Aber die ganzen Erklärvideos, die ganzen …
Erklärvideos, Wahlberichterstattung.
Alles mögliche.
Alles das könnte ich sofort irgendwie …
sofort. Ich müsste dafür die Standardverträge ändern, ich müsste die Vergütungsregeln ändern,
derzeit gibt es noch so Dinge, die auch anachronistisch sind im Internet, die Wiederholungshonorare.
Ach echt immer noch?
Ja klar, und der SWR hat gerade acht Jahre verhandelt für einen neuen Tarifvertrag.
Ist natürlich unfassbar schwierig.
Ich finde, ich würde sagen, man sollte das, und da sind wir schon auch wieder ein bisschen dezentral,
selbststeuernde Teams, das sind ja Redaktionen und ich würde sagen, lasst doch die Redaktionen entscheiden,
aber ermöglicht es ihnen.
Das heißt zum Beispiel, wenn eine Redaktion sagt, wir hoffen einfach auf Wiederholungshonorare, okay.
Aber wenn die Redaktion sagt, Wiederholungshonorare ist doch irrelevant, wir wollen lieber auf Wikipedia mit unseren Beiträgen Leute erreichen,
dann kriegen die vielleicht sogar einen Bonus dafür, dass sie das sofort frei lizenzieren, dafür gibt es sicher keine Wiederholungshonorare,
aber dann sollen die das entscheiden und das muss ich halt möglich machen.
Also man hat es gesehen, TerraX hat jetzt als erstes mal so ein Pilotprojekt gemacht und hat fünf kurze Clips zum Klimawandel,
weil Thema der Stunde, unter einer freien Lizenz veröffentlicht.
Binnen kürzester Zeit sind die in zig Wikipedia-Artikeln in mehreren Sprachversionen gelandet.
Zum Beispiel im Artikel zu Klimawandel ist jetzt so ein kurzes Video, das hat im Monat über 500.000 Aufrufe,
alleine die Wikipedia-Seite nur in der deutschen Version, oder deutsch und englisch, ich weiß nicht, egal.
Aber der Punkt ist, dass man diese Chance auslässt und da braucht man nicht mal eine Rundfunkstaatsänderung dazu.
Das ist was ich nicht verstehen kann, wo ich jetzt die letzten dreieinhalb pain in the ass war
und quasi bei jeder Gelegenheit da drauf geblieben bin.
Da war dann die Frage, ja …
Wobei man dann nicht nur die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen adressieren muss, dass das eigentlich auch eine Aufforderung an alle YouTuber,
die in irgendeiner Form versuchen …
So Erklärvideos machen.
Ja, also was für ein Potenzial man da hätte und in dem Moment …
Ich meine, das ist das Interessante an dieser ganzen Klimawandeldebatte gerade und dieser allgemein anerkannten Dringlichkeit der Situation,
nach dem Motto, wenn man das ohnehin so sieht mit, ja also entweder passiert jetzt was oder Sintflut,
dann sind irgendwie die Copyright-Regeln dann auch egal, weil die schwimmen dann einfach genauso mit dem anderen Ölfilm dahin
und dann kann man es auch wieder gleich freigeben.
Wobei ich finde, den anderen YouTubern, die vielleicht damit Geld verdienen wollen oder sagen,
wer weiß, vielleicht mache ich mal eine DVD, okay hüstel, aber da muss ich sagen,
ist trotzdem der Anspruch an einen beitragsfinanzierten Rundfunk ein anderer.
Der muss sich an einem anderen Anspruch messen lassen als private Medien.
Da wäre aber wiederum auch das einen Chance, die Legitimität im digitalen Zeitalter so richtig zu unterfüttern,
indem ich sage, schaut, kein Privater wird die Dinge jemals so zur Verfügung stellen, dass ihr sie auf eurem Blog nutzen könnt,
sie in der Wikipedia stehen können und außerdem noch in Bildungsunterlagen einfach eingebettet werden können.
Und ja da merkt man, das hat vielleicht so gewirkt, das ist alles all over the place hier,
aber eigentlich kommt dann irgendwie so Wikipedia, freie Lizenzen, OpenSource und öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk kommt dann schon irgendwie zusammen.
Schauen wir mal, also Podcasts werden ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört, falls das mit der Sintflut nicht doch noch kommt.
Es gab ja mal so ein Projekt, WikiNews, der Versuch sozusagen Tagesschau zu sein.
Das hat nicht ganz so gegriffen, aber warum die Tagesschau nicht gleich da veröffentlicht, wir wissen es nicht.
Leonhard vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Ich danke vielmals für die Einladung, hier teilzunehmen.
Ja sehr gerne und natürlich auch vielen Dank für das Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Bald geht es wieder weiter.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.